Corona-Ausbruch instant
Ja, ich wusste, ich wusste gerade weg, ich kann euch gleich erzählen was war
Nichts Schlimmes
Oh, was hab ich da noch auf, ah von gestern
Exquisite
So ich weiß nicht ob noch irgendjemand da ist, ich mein, ich bin ja relativ plötzlich,
ich wusste relativ plötzlich oft vor eineinhalb Stunden oder so
Twitch sagt 46 Leute waren dauerhaft und sind instant wieder da, okay
Oh eineinhalb Stunden ist ein bisschen zu übertrieben oder
Na doch 2 Stunden, eineinhalb Stunden, 2 Stunden war ich weg ja
Ich bin 16.30 oft ja, 1.45 war ich oft
Ich muss weg
Kann man Update machen während hier das Stream wieder anläuft
Wir machen einfach, wir machen exakt an der Stelle weiter
Oh was das, der Specter Meltdown Checker
Was das, muss ich gucken was das ist
Was ist der Specter Meltdown Checker
Was das, Checker
Specter Meltdown Checker, wow, wow
Spotmonka
Guckt doch mal hier, der Specter Meltdown Checker sagt
Ich bin verwundbar, aber ich bin ja zum Glück in der VM
Weil das auch nicht alles ausschließt
Guckt euch das mal an hier
Der Specter Meltdown Checker
Was das alles gibt
Mit Root, mit Root soll ich das starten
Okay mal gucken was da der Specter Meltdown Checker sagt
Ha, ich bin safe, außer gegen das hier
Okay, who cares
Hat mich nur gewundert, hat mich nur gewundert was das ist
Ja Leute ich musste kurz weg, ich musste vorhin kurz weg
Es ist ein Exquisite Update, Huge Update
Leute mal ernsthaft, ich hab sie nicht mehr alle oder
Ich laber so ein dummes Zeug vor mich hin manchmal
Und wisst ihr wo das noch schlimmer war
Als ich mit dem Friseur immer, als wir zusammen Xbox gespielt haben
Ohne Stream, ohne alles, wir haben einen Scheiß geschwätzt die ganze Zeit
Das ist echt nicht normal gewesen
Da ist das was ich hier vor mich hin laber, nix dagegen
Keckweight, Keckhyperweight
Also jetzt wo da wieder ein paar Leute da sind
Wobei ich warte nochmal bis das Stream richtig angelaufen ist
Kann ich euch erzählen warum ich eben wegpuste
Ganz einfach
Moment, erstmal den Controller anschließen, lull
Ja sieht echt so aus
Also warum ich vor eineinhalb Stunden einfach off gegangen bin
Ich hab vergessen, dass ich verabredet war
Ah, geht das Kabel nochmal rein heute
Reset
Connecting Wifi
Alles klar, passt
Gut, also jetzt
Genau, also wo stehe ich, wo bin ich stehen geblieben
Also warum ich weg war, ich war mit meinem Nachbar verabredet, wir wollten Reifen tauschen
Also Reifenwechsel, das geht zu zweit halt viel easier
Das hab ich komplett vergessen
PP-Steer, doch hatten wir
Hatten wir
Haben die das entfernt was ich hatte
Doch, Monka, Monkas-Steer haben wir
Ich wusste noch, dass ich das hinzugefügt hab
Ja
Wieso geht da für Autocomplete nicht, doch bei mir hat's funktioniert
Sonst ich hab einfach Doppelpunkt Steer eingegeben, da hat er's gefunden
Weil
Ansonsten hätte ich das doch jetzt auch nicht entdeckt
Auch vielleicht sind die Emotes minimal zu groß
Ihr wurdet ok-champed
Echt nicht?
Guck mal, sogar hier
Sogar hier Autocompleted, ohne dass ich eingeloggt bin
Und kleingeschrieben auch
Das ist FFZ
Ist das FZ
Ja, vielleicht liegt's da dran
Also ich bin ja hin und hergerissen
Also FFZ ist ja eigentlich
Find ich der schönere Plugin, aber ich find die
Die Policy da teilweise doof, dass sie Emotes löschen
Wobei bei der Twitch-TV hat auch Emotes gelöscht
Scheiß drauf, ja
Who cares? Toss
Was Toss ist, fliegt halt raus, so ist das halt auf Twitch
Ja Leute, also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich versuch das jetzt nochmal ganz kurz zu
Zu erklären, wo wir stehen geblieben sind
Wir bauen immer noch, also weil der Patrick gerade gesagt hat, es dauert schon 10 Streams
Ich hab ja eigentlich außer in einem Stream noch gar nichts gemacht
Vorher bin ich einfach easy instant off gegangen, weil ich Reifen wechseln musste
Also, ich hab so ein paar Sensoren
Und davon hab ich einem Kühlschrank liegen
Und den will ich auslesen, dass ich erkenne, ob meine Kühlschrank hier offen ist
Oder ob die Temperatur steigt, ja genau, so viel
Das ist der Hintergrund dazu
Dazu hab ich hier so ein Board
Reifenwechselchamp, ja
Dann hab ich hier so ein Board und darauf läuft das Ganze
Wir haben das selbst programmiert und der Trick dabei ist
Ich lese das rein passiv aus, also ich frag den Sensor nicht ab
Sondern der Sensor schickt alle 30 Sekunden Daten und ich frag das
Also ich lese das einfach aus, was der schickt, d.h. das beeinflusst null die Batterie
Und ich frag alle 5 Stunden
Alle 5 Stunden
Frag ich die Batterie ab
Wer sich schon immer mal gefragt hat
Wie viel 5 Stunden in Microseconds sind
Der weiß es jetzt
Das sind 18, ok warte, warte, warte, Sekunde, Sekunde
Kann es hier bloß so was eigentlich?
Kann das das?
Nee, kann es nicht, oder? Vielleicht mit Komma?
Das wäre ja auch zu schön, wenn die sowas könnten
Also das sind was? 18 Milliarden?
18 Milliarden Microsekunden
Wenn dann mit Komma
Nee, nee, nee, 1000er Trendzeichen ist ein Punkt
Wobei das ist ja Kokona
Also in C Sharp gibt es das?
Separator?
Ach ist das Kokona oben das Ding?
Also man kann nämlich in
Man kann nämlich in Dortnet mittlerweile die Sachen so schreiben
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass man das so schreiben muss
Was ist das überhaupt? Patrick, was für ein komisches? Ach das ist ein Single Quote, ne?
Ja, aber das wird nicht funktionieren
Wenn das funktioniert, dann kecke ich eine Runde
Wait a minute
Ernsthaft?
Fuck, das geht
Ok Leute, ich hab zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben, ihr werdet es nicht glauben
Ich hab was gefunden an C++, was ich nicht total kacke finde
Die haben sich ja mal was dabei gedacht
Ich wusste das auch nicht
Mal gucken wie das Feature heißt
Tatsächlich seit 2014 geht das schon
Das ist ja mal
Die erste, ok ne das stimmt nicht, es ist die zweite Sache, die ich an C++ ganz gut finde
Das erste, was ich an C++ ganz gut finde, dass man
Compile Time String Längen checken kann
Also wenn ich beispielsweise eine Methode hab, wo ich sag hey, mein
Mein Name darf nur maximal 15 Zeichen lang sein
Dann kann ich das quasi zur Compile Zeit checken lassen, das ist auch ganz nice
Aber ansonsten habe ich immer nichts gefunden, was ich geil finde an C++
Gibt es wahrscheinlich auch einfach nix
Ja
By the way, ich hab mir überlegt, Leute, muss ich euch mal fragen
Ich hab mir überlegt ein Video zu machen morgen über
Was es sich lohnt, was man auf seinem, was man selbst, was ich daheim betreiben kann
So an Software, was man selbst hosten kann und was ich da für sinnvoll halte
Ich brauche ein bisschen reißerischen Titel, so der perfekte Heimserver oder irgendwie sowas
Muss ich mir noch was überlegen
Die Sache ist bloß die, ich hab keine Ahnung
Ob die meisten Leute damit was anfangen können
Weil bei den meisten Leuten ist nach
Wir installieren einen Raspberry Pi mit einer Nextcloud ist fertig
Mehr kriegen die nicht gebacken
Ja
Also die, die meisten Leute machen den Nass auf den Raspberry Pi oder sowas
Wobei ein Raspberry Pi fürs Nass so eines der schlechtesten Geräte überhaupt ist
Und
Ohne Nextcloud und Nextcloud sackt halt, es ist halt
Es ist halt nix dabei, was mir gefällt, ne
Also doch, nix dabei
So bei dem, was ich hab, was die Leute wahrscheinlich gefällt
Ich finde, man kann schon durchaus die eine oder andere sinnvollen Sachen machen
Also ich bin tatsächlich froh, dass ich mittlerweile gültige Zertifikate bei mir lokal habe
Weil klar, das wird wahrscheinlich meistens kein Jucken, aber ich find gültige Zertifikate lokal bei mir echt nice
Mein PXE Boot lokal ist auch ultra poggers
Also da freu ich mich jedes mal, wenn ich PXE ne VM starten kann
Meine, ähm
Hardware Teile Verwaltung, wo ich weiß in welcher Schublade was liegt, find ich auch praktisch
Zehn Gründe, warum jeder mindestens ein vollbestücktes 42er Airwreck zuhause haben sollte
PXE lokal wird, wie, wie
Du musst PXE lokal machen, wie willst du es denn sonst machen
PXE as a service, sowas gibt's glaub ich noch nicht
Wobei, wobei, Max, man weiß ja nie
Wisst zwar nicht, wie das gehen soll, aber
Achso daheim, das ist total einfach daheim
Du nimmst einfach net boot, x, y, z
Du nimmst, du nimmst den Container
Und startest den und es war's
Du kannst jetzt irgendeine x beliebigen Rechner booten oder VM booten
Und du kannst installieren, was du willst und live CD booten, was du willst
Das ist echt praktisch und im Prinzip kein Admin Aufwand wirklich
Ja, ich bin wieder am Start, ich bin wieder am Start
Ich musste Reifen wechseln gehen, ich muss Monka, Moment
Monkastier muss ich machen
Ja, kannst du, habe ich aber net gemacht, weil so ziemlich alles dabei ist, was ich brauche
Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst in so einem Minimal Environment booten
Und von dort an weiter booten, wenn du irgendwie ein ISO Link hast
Ich finde es praktisch, zumal es kaum Aufwand ist
Ich finde es enorm praktisch, dass ich auch alle möglichen Live CDs und so am Start habe
Einfach eine VM starten und gut ist
Ich finde es ganz praktisch
Gut, ich meine so, sag mal so
Home Assistant Installer oder so ist nicht dabei
Also ein paar Sachen wären schon nice zum Testen, aber wie oft installierst du das
Ah, das habe ich vermiert
Test System und Live System und gut ist
Was ein Lüfter verliert, Öl?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die Öl verlieren können
Na, mit Netboot geht das
Netboot ist ja das coole dran, dass die, die haben quasi so ein mini PXE Environment
Und wenn du da drüber startest, kannst du alles mögliche auswählen
Unter anderem in, in, du kannst in irgendeinen Crub booten
Und von dort irgendwie weitere ISOs booten übers Netzwerk
Und so ganz grad abgedrehtes Zeug benutze ich im Prinzip eigentlich nie
Aber ich weiß, dass es geht
Hey Max, ich hätte Lust in Richtung DevOps zu gehen
Hast du vielleicht Tipps, was ich alles drauf haben sollte?
Ich mache aktuell Ausbildungen zu Physi
In welchem Bereich machst du aktuell eine Ausbildung?
Also sprich, was machst du denn so?
Ja, wenn du jetzt beispielsweise den ganzen Tag Druckerpatronen taust
Ist es schwierig, sich mit irgendwelchen Clouds zu beschäftigen?
So in welchem Bereich bist du denn gerade?
Mein Physi, ich würde mal ehrlich sagen
Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration ist, ist, ist
Ich weiß nicht, ob es einen Beruf gibt, der vielfältiger ist von dem, wo man am Endeffekt landen kann
Und das, was man im Endeffekt machen könnte, ja
Also, wie unterschiedlich das ist, je nachdem, wo man landet
Skalierung in drei Monaten, huge subscription, massive big brain sub
Ich meine, es gibt so ein paar Basics, Sachen, die sich immer lohnen zu lernen
Das würde mich erstmal interessieren, was du so gerade machst
Na ja, dann schieß mal los, dann sag ich dir auch was zu
Wie viele PCs besitzt du?
Du meinst welche, die ich aktiv benutze?
Die ich theoretischen Einzelteilen hier noch habe
Ich finde Finish nice
Das ist halt was, wo du privat nicht wirklich Anwendungszweck für hast, für Terraform
Ja, da ist er wieder, richtig
Ja, ich musste, ich musste hier, ich musste folgendes machen
Heute ist Tanzverbot, ich weiß
Ich bin in einem Verlag tätig und mach da User Support
MonkaS
Okay, vielleicht gefällts dir, gefällts dir?
Gefällt dir User Support?
Nur so
Jetzt Interesse halber
Ich finde User Support ist der größte Scheiß überhaupt
Das ist, ich glaube, das ist Mario Sunshine Musik
Okay, ich mach da User Support aber auch Serververwaltung
Leider kein Docker Kubernetes und auch Cloud
Also, okay, also wenn du sagst, du hast beispielsweise auf der Arbeit
Da bist gar nicht in dem Bereich
Und du suchst auch was, wo du später vielleicht was von hast, wenn du den Arbeitgeber wechselst oder so
Also, eine Sache, die prinzipiell immer gut ankommt, ist Automatisierung aller Art
Sei es sowas wie Ansible oder Puppet
Puppet ist ein bisschen oldschooligere Variante
Server-Automatisierung oder generell, wie nennt sich das so cool heutzutage?
Lifecycle-Management
Ja, aber ich bleib mal bei System- oder Server-Automatisierung
Das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll
Das ist sowohl sinnvoll, wenn du Cloud-Geschichten machst als auch wenn man viel Lokal hat
Wobei man ja auch mittlerweile nicht mal Lokal sagt
Also Leute, die richtig coolen Cloud-Natives
Die sagen nicht mehr Lokal, die sagen On-Premise
Weil Cloud ist ja mittlerweile schon Standard bei denen im Kopf
Und deswegen, alles was nicht Cloud ist, muss man explizit als On-Premise erzählen
Und wer dann noch cooler ist
Wer noch nen Tick cooler ist als die oberkrassen Cloud-Native Leute
Die sagen nicht On-Premises oder On-Premise
Die sagen On-Prem
Weil On-Prem so klingt, als hat man das schon 30 Millionen mal gesagt
Und indem man das abkürzt, ist man eigentlich noch ne Ecke cooler
Lokal ist für mich Lokal bei einem am Standort
Jetzt nicht bei sich auf dem Host oder sonst wo
Lokal-Räumlich-Lokal
Sagt man nicht mehr
Früher hat man das umgeschrieben mit Lokal im eigenen Rechenzentrum
Offline, wie auch immer
Wenn du was Richtung Ansible Server Automatisierung kannst
Dann ist das prinzipiell für alles nützlich
Wie gesagt, Puppet gibt es auch
Bei uns auf der Arbeit ist viel Puppet
Aber ich persönlich finde Ansible viel schöner
Also habe ich auch im Stream mal ein bisschen gelernt
So, und die Sache ist die
Da hast du überall was von
Und das ist eindeutig ne Sache, was in Richtung
So in diesen DevOps-Bereich fällt
Das ist nicht mehr so die Hardcore-Hackerman
Ich sitze vorm Terminal und tippe den ganzen nach kryptische Dinge ein
Sondern du machst Sachen reproduzierbar, automatisierbar
Das ist eindeutig was in diesen DevOps-Bereich reinfällt
Dann solltest du dir Build-Tools angucken
Wir machen mal so ne Textdatei
Weil das wird öfters mal gefragt
Also das erste was man sich angucken kann ist
Automatisierung
Zum Beispiel so was wie Ansible oder Puppet
Oder Chef gibt es da noch
Oder so was
Naja, Terraform passt nicht so wirklich
Terraform ist eher ein Infrastruktur-Provisioning-System
So was in der Richtung
Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine sinnvolle Geschichte
Build-Tools ist das nächste
Weil schon einmal was von Jenkins geschrieben hat
Build-Tools ist das nächste, was man sich mal angucken sollte
Wenn man sich für diesen Bereich interessiert
Also Jenkins ist die Oldschool-Variante
So was wie GitHub Actions ist zurzeit auch relativ angesagt
Oder Azure
Wobei das will ich nicht empfehlen
Ich finde das suckt
Diese Azure DevOps-Geschichte gefällt mir persönlich überhaupt nicht
Ich finde GitHub Actions ist eine nice Geschichte
Genau Circle, Drone hast du da noch
Circle, sonst was
Ich mag es nicht
Ich weiß nicht
Man kann das verwenden, aber schön finde ich es nicht
Genau
Das nächste ist Versionsverwaltung
Da gibt es eigentlich nur Shit zurzeit
Also mehr gibt es da nicht
Im Prinzip sollte man sich dann dazu noch angucken
Man sollte klarkommen dann mit Frontends
So was, GitHub, GitLab, Bitbucket
Was man lokal verwendet
So was in der Richtung sollte man sich angucken
Nein, SVN schreibe ich da nicht mehr
Nein, CVS
CVS
CVS sind die Tabellen
Nein, hör mal plus auf
Shit ist das einzige was man sich angucken muss
Shit im Jahr 2021
Rest kannst du vergessen
Inklusive was man sich auch noch angucken
Deployment und development workflows
Also sowas wie Branches
Feature requests
Roadmap DevOps
Echt, das ist eine leiste Map
Da sage ich jetzt mal was zu
Da reakte ich jetzt mal drauf
Huge React Content
Now we have YouTube Channel
Excellent
Roadmap
Also was sagt denn die Roadmap?
Zeigt mal her
DevOps
Feature requests hatte ich schon drin
Okay, es kommt aufs gleiche raus
Also was haben wir denn hier?
Learn a programming language
Das ist tatsächlich kein schlechter Ratschlag
Wobei man ehrlich sagen muss
Man kann, wenn man da richtig hardcore Hacker-Man-Admin ist
Man kann durchaus was in diese Richtung machen
Ohne jetzt der super gute Programmierer zu sein
Aber mal ganz im Ernst
Man kommt heutzutage eigentlich nicht mehr drum herum
Es gibt ganz viele Admins, die da immer noch
Vor allem so die richtigen oldschool Admins
Die so mit Programmieren überhaupt nichts anfangen können
Wo ein Bash-Script aus 10 Zeilen das höchste der Gefühle ist
Ich habe euch auch die Story von der Arbeit erzählt
Wo einer von mir
Wo einer gesagt hat
Ich weiß gar nicht wie detailliert ich euch das erzählt habe
Ich soll in einem Key-Value-Store so einen Jason
Nein, kein Jason
Ich soll einen Setting in so einem Key-Value-Store anpassen
Habe ich euch das erzählt?
Und wo der dann meinte
Ich soll zwei Werte reinschreiben
Also der hat einen Ticketpaus aufgemacht
Und meinte
Er braucht jetzt unter einem Key
Braucht er zwei Werte
Und da habe ich ihn gefragt
Ja, okay
Wie will er das haben?
Wie will er das machen mit zwei Werten?
Ich könnte ihm einen Jason-Array reinschreiben
Ich mache ihm einen Jason-Array rein
Und Wert 1, Wert 2
Und dann meinte er
Nein, das geht nicht
Er möchte zwei Werte haben
Aber das ist ein Key-Value-Store
Das heißt nicht sonst Key-Value
Das ist 1 zu 1
Da gibt es keine zwei Werte
Es gibt einfach nur einen Key und ein Value
Und wenn er mehrere Sachen drinstehen haben will
Dann braucht er irgendwas
Was er, irgendeinen Text in er passt
Und am Ende bekommt er zwei Values raus
Es geht nicht anders
Und er hat darauf bestanden
Nein, nein, nein
Ich möchte dieses Kommando ausführen
Und ich will zwei Werte rausbekommen
Ja, also du hast schon
Da nicht so die Profis teilweise am Start
Und das sind halt Leute
Die angeblich Entwickler sind bei uns
Und schon von Entwicklersachen keine Ahnung haben
Also das ist ja eigentlich
Der Ernstfall
Also das sollte nicht so sein
Zumindest man kann
Sicherlich die ein oder anderen Sachen machen
Aber
Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall
Eine Programmiersprache zu lernen
Es ist fast egal welche
Es würde sich halt anbieten
Irgendwas, was zur Zeit angesagt ist
Also zum Beispiel
Die Option hier
Kann ich ja mal was zu sagen
Ich persönlich bin der Meinung
Das hat er hier übrigens gar nicht drinstehen
Die beste Einstiegsprogrammiersprache
Ist
JavaScript
Aber nicht mit Node.js
Sondern mit ganz klassisch CSS, HTML
Wenn man nicht genau weiß
Was man machen möchte, wohlgemerkt
Wenn man schon weiß, was man machen will
So was wie Python raussuchen
C++
Also da bin ich nicht mit einverstanden
Mit den Vorschlägen
Von dieser Seite
Da bin ich nicht zu
Da bin ich nicht mit einverstanden
Also ich würde sagen, wenn man keine Ahnung hat, was man machen will
Dann
Nimmt man sich
JavaScript, nimmt man sich einen Browser
JavaScript, CSS, HTML
Denn am Frontend kommt man nicht vorbei
So viel hat er hier schon mal gar nicht drinstehen
Das heißt, ich muss meine
Frontend
Zeugs bisschen anschauen
CSS, HTML, JS
Ich gebe ihm recht
Dass man Programmier
Sprache lernen
Da gebe ich ihm recht
Aber wie gesagt, das würde ich nehmen
Ich würde sagen
CSS, HTML, JavaScript
Wenn man keine Ahnung hat, was man genau machen will
Einfach weil ich der Meinung bin
Es ist am motivierendsten
Man sieht
Was passiert
Und das sieht man mit JavaScript, CSS, HTML am besten
Und
Man bleibt dann dementsprechend auch dran
Weil ich glaube, es kennt jeder
Der angefangen hat eine Programmiersprache zu lernen
Und
Dann sich denkt
Okay, was mache ich denn damit jetzt
Und mit CSS, JavaScript, HTML
Hast du erstmal relativ endlose Möglichkeiten
Was zu machen, weil jeder denkt
In Webseiten heutzutage
Bei den anderen Sachen wird es dann
Schwierig, wenn du keinen konkreten Anwendungsfall schon mal hast
Und deswegen finde ich
Das motiviert
Einfach am meisten dran zu bleiben
Und dazu kommt
Man kommt an Frontend Sachen heutzutage nicht vorbei
Man kleine Webinterfaces
Bauen musst du heute wirklich an jede Ecke
Und auch Frontend Sachen
Verstehen musst du, da kommst du eigentlich nicht dran vorbei
So, das nächste ist
Was man auf jeden Fall wissen muss
Das mache ich nochmal davor
Linux lernen und
Kommandozeile
Das ist wichtig
SSH
Ja
So zu Sachen
DevOps
Da könnte ich
Ohne Scheiß, da könnte ich doch ein Video drüber machen
Oder
How to DevOps
Ich weiß nicht, ob es jemand großartig interessiert
Aber das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee
Oder
So
Telnet
Ja
Wusstet ihr, dass Windows standardmäßig kein Telnet kann
Achso, ja stimmt, ich hab's nachher erzählt
Windows kann standardmäßig kein Telnet
Man muss
Man muss sagen
Turn Windows Features on und off
Telnet klein, Häkchen und okay
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob nicht
PowerShell was dabei hat
Machen wir mal mit der Geschichte weiter
Gibt's andere Roadmaps
One and Backend DevOps
Also
Okay, ich muss noch was zum Thema
Programmiersprachen sagen
Ich bin kein
Ich bin kein großartiger Frontend Pro
Ich kann, ich muss halt sagen
Ich kann alles halbwegs
Also alles jetzt jetzt
Übertrieben sein, ich kann relativ
Breitflächig Dinge, ja
Von Linux zu ein bisschen Low Level
Programmieren, zu Frontend Sachen
Alle möglichen, bisschen Elektronik
Für alle möglichen Sachen
Und was ich halt mache ist
Warum ich mich mit manchen Themen auch relativ gut
auskenne
Ist, wenn ich ein Problem hab
Was mich persönlich interessiert
Dann mach ich da auch ein halbes Jahr dran rum
Bis das Scheiß funktioniert und ich es kapiert hab
Deswegen kenn ich mich mittlerweile auch ganz gut
Mit WebRTC und sowas zum Beispiel aus
Weil ich diese
Weil ich Kamera Streaming Software programmieren wollte
T-shaped DevOps, genau
Aber ich muss jetzt noch was zum Thema
Programmiersprachen sagen
Am Einstieg, hab ich ja schon gesagt
So, und von den Programmiersprachen
Die hier sonst noch drinnen stehen muss ich sagen
JavaScript, klar haben wir schon abgehackt, Node.js
Ruby ist persönlich
Neben C-Sharp meine
Mit Abstand Lieblingsprogrammiersprache
C-Sharp und Ruby, gefallen mir persönlich am besten
Allerdings das Problem an Ruby ist
Ich glaub Ruby benutzt
Keiner mehr
Ruby Projekte auf GitHub sind
Zum größten Teil dead, Ausnahmen bestätigen
Die Regel
Ja
Was die Natra zum Beispiel macht
Letztes Commit
Ok, vor 19 Tagen größere Projekte sind noch aktiv
Aber, also viele Ruby Projekte
Sind dead
Siehst du auch an GitHub
Und es gibt wenig neue Ruby Projekte
Ruby ist eine super Sprache, es kam letztens auch erst Version 3
Raus, Flixcoder, 5 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub
Hups, komplett falsche Emotes
Lul
Monka, Corona, Dankeschön für den Sub
Aber Ruby ist ziemlich dead
Es kam letztens Version 3 raus
Die angeblich deutlich schneller ist
Benchmarks bestätigen das
Ruby 3 ist wohl auch eine ganze Ecke schneller
Aber natürlich bei weitem hier nicht in diesen Region
Und das Problem ist
Was man mit Ruby hat
So cool Ruby ist, außer dir
Wenn du dann Ruby kannst, kann keiner Ruby
Und macht keiner was in Ruby
Was halt ziemlich sackt, früher war Ruby so eine
So die richtig krasse
Rockstar Developer Language
Wo alle, die sich geil fanden, Ruby gebastelt haben
Wir können uns Ruby 3 mal angucken
Ja
Ja Patrick, das kopiere ich mal
Eins zu eins da so rein
Ich würde
Noch ein paar Sachen vielleicht
Bisschen
Bisschen seht, hast schon ein bisschen AWK
Vielleicht noch
Ja, Zeugs
We get
Die üblichen Sachen
Und deswegen könnt ihr Ruby eigentlich
Vergessen 2021
To go komme ich gleich, Flixcoder
Also deswegen
Ruby ist eine coole Sprache
Aber Ruby ist eigentlich dead und
Ja
Tot, irgendwie heutzutage
Die nächste beste Option ist Pyzen
Ganz ohne Scheiß
Wenn ihr
Wenn
Wenn euch das nicht so liegt
Mit JavaScript, HTML, CSS, Frontend
Mäßig, dann fangt mit Pyzen an
Das ist
Würde ich mal sagen, vom Hype her
Und von den
Zukunftsträchtigen Technologien und sowas
Ist das die Sprache Nummer eins zur Zeit
Guckt euch, guckt euch auf GitHub um
Die ganzen
90% der ganzen Machine Learning
Sachen, doch ich war oft
Ich musste Reifen wechseln
Wieder da, das hat auch nicht so ewig gedauert
Genau, Twitter
Twitter war Ruby on Rails, Twitch weiß ich nicht
Twitter war Ruby on Rails, aber Twitter
Ist schon ganz lange auf Java
Ich weiß nicht, was die geritten hat
Ich glaube, ist das nicht sogar Clojure
Oder so mittlerweile?
Ne nicht Clojure, wie heißt das andere?
Scala? Ach was weiß ich
Vielleicht haben sie auch schon wieder alles geändert
Genau und
ShitHub
War auch mal Ruby, glaube ich
Immer noch, ja?
Ich glaube, GitHub ist immer noch Ruby
Der Grund, warum man in Unis Java lernen
Ist, weil es so viele Leute gibt, die Java können
Ja, also ich würde sagen
Das können wir uns auch gleich angucken
Also ich würde sagen, dass Pyzen aktuell
Die angesagteste Programmiersprache ist
Neben JavaScript
So die richtig prestigeträchtigen
Zukunftsrechtlichen Sachen sind teilweise
Oftmals in Pyzen, also das ist auf jeden Fall
Nicht verkehrt
Das zu lernen, das ist eine super erste Programmiersprache
Ich persönlich mag ein bisschen mehr
Die ganze JavaScript, CSS Geschichte
Weil ich es motivierender finde zum Anstiegen
Beides kann man nicht verkehrt machen
Und ganz ehrlich, man sollte
Wenn man das eine Weile macht
Man sollte beides schon mal benutzt haben
Ich muss sagen
Ich mache nicht oft was in Pyzen, aber jedes Mal
Wenn ich es mache, muss ich sagen, finde ich das unglaublich angenehm
Ich habe zum Beispiel einen
Converter programmiert auf der Arbeit von
Moment, jetzt haltet euch
Jetzt haltet euch fest
Von Windows DHCP Settings
Zu Linux DHCP Settings
Das war ein bisschen eklig, aber
Ja, Mock als Tier, genau
Aber es hat gut funktioniert
Und ich muss sagen, ich war echt begeistert davon
Weil wieder
Wie viel super Sachen eingebaut sind
Du hast in Pyzen standardmäßig
Einen Standardlib eingebaut
Einen CSV-Parser
Für Tabellen
Du hast standardmäßig einen IP-Calculator
Weil der Windows
Wusstet ihr, dass der Windows DHCP Server
Verbackt ist
Der Windows DHCP Server erlaubt es
Dass du als Start-IP
Das Netz nimmst, anstatt
Die erste IP im Netz
Also der ICS zumindest erlaubt das nicht
Das heißt, ich musste
Jedes Mal
Wenn ich diese Config gepasst habe
Musste ich jedes Mal zu dem Netz
Eins dazurechnen, weil die halt
Ein Windows Feature
Nennen wir es mal
Ausgenutzt haben, die Typen, die den
Windows DHCP betreuen bei uns
Und da war ich echt froh, dass es einen IP-Calculator
Gibt in Pyzen, in der Standardlib
Dem habe ich das Subnetz gegeben
Das Netz, abgesagt IP plus eins
Und hat das ausgerechnet, also war echt eine super
Geschichte. Jedes Mal, wenn ich damit was mache
Finde ich es eigentlich gut
So, auch eine super Sprache
Zum Einstieg. Früher habe ich gesagt, Ruby
Ich habe sogar mal ein Video gemacht zu Ruby
Mit, warum das eine gute Programmiersprache ist
Ich finde es mittlerweile, es ist eine geile
Programmiersprache, aber es ist einfach dead
Also, sehr gut zum Einstieg, auch gut zum
Einstieg, aber im Browser nicht unbedingt als NodeShare
Man soll es sich aber mit Node auf jeden Fall mal auseinandersetzen
Kommen wir mal zu der Seite
Damit bin ich nicht wirklich einverstanden
Muss ich sagen
Ähm, also
Mit C++ fangen wir mal
Gar nicht an
C++ ist einfach Schrott
Und definitiv nicht das, was sich
Jemand zum Einstieg geben sollte, es sei denn
Du möchtest ihn abschrecken vor
Live, dass er nie wieder was mit zu tun haben will
Man könnte fast denken, Stadia ist in
C++ programmiert oder so
Also, C++ auf gar keinen Fall
Zum Einstieg, gerade auch nicht für die
DevOps-Geschichte, da ist es da
Wenig interessant die Sprache
Eigentlich für
C genauso wesig, wobei
C eine schöne Sprache ist, C++ nicht
Aber gerade im DevOps-Programm
Ist C jetzt auch nicht so das
So das Ding, was du oft siehst
Da ist Python auf jeden Fall
Die bessere Variante
Rust ist auch eine coole Sprache
Aber Rust ist
In diesem Bereich jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig
relevant
Was ich machen würde, ist auf jeden Fall
Go
Ja, Rust
Ist only, only, only for
Elevenhead, Leute
Ja, das stimmt, also
Rust ist wirklich
Die Syntax ist
Zweckt mir, ich finde die Syntax jetzt auch nicht so
Wahnsinnig klar
Vor allem, wenn du dann irgendwie
Lifetime spezifizieren musst, von wie was
Voneinander abhängt, also dass es, also
Es ist wirklich expanding
Gehirn, dass du das kannst
Und in diesem Bereich jetzt auch gar nicht
So wahnsinnig relevant
Eigentlich
Moment, wir unterbrechen mal kurz das
Aktuelle Programm, um diese Frage hier zu beantworten
Moin, hab hier noch zwei
ESP
32 rumliegen, mit einem will ich
LED-Leist per WLAN ansteuern, dir mal
Eine Idee, was man mit dem zweiten am Sinn voll zu anstellen kann
Ja, noch mehr LEDs
Also, komm, RGB kann man nicht genug haben
LEDs, einfach noch mehr LEDs
Wenn dir das erste
Gefällt, dann mach einfach noch einen zweiten
LED-Strip, easy
Okay
Also, die unteren Dinger bin ich kein Fan
Gerade weil es um diese DevOps-Geschichten geht
Die zwei coole Sprachen, C++
Schrott, aber die zwei coole
Sprachen, wir müssen übrigens gleich
C++ machen, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Paints-Champ
So, Go
Auf jeden Fall, Go ist eines der
Wichtigsten Sprachen überhaupt im DevOps
Und vor allem im Cloud-Unfeld
90%
70% der Tools
Sei es das Kubernetes-Grammstab Terraform
Auch und überall, wo du hinguckst und wo du
Hinspuckst, triffst du auf Go
Programme und Libraries
Wenn es nicht in Go ist, dann ist es
In Python oder in Node
Im Prinzip gibt es diese drei Programmiersprachen dort
Es ist entweder in Go
Zum größten Teil ist es in Python
Oder es ist vielleicht in Node
So, damit habt ihr 99% der Sachen
Die man in diesem Bereich so benutzt abgedeckt
Node, Python, Go, vor allem Go
Dazu muss ich sagen
Go ist an sich
Keine Sprache
Die ich jetzt zu sehr flamen kann
Go ist schon in Ordnung
Ich habe die Kamera-Geschichte
Ich habe diesen
Kamera-Web-ATC-Streaming-Sache in Go gemacht
Ich muss sagen
Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass ich nicht so die wahnsinnige
So die wirklich
Jahrzehnte Erfahrung
In Go jetzt habe, aber
Es gibt ein paar Sachen
Die mich an Go stören
Das ist zum Beispiel
Dass die Standard-Library irgendwie
Bisschen wenig
Drinnen hat
Also
Zum Beispiel
Du hast
Du hast in Go
Hast du keine Möglichkeit
Ja, Channels und das ganze Zeug
Was Go so
Eingeführt ist schon eine coole Sache
Aber die Standard-Library ist ein bisschen
Cluster heißt das glaube ich
Also da fehlt ein bisschen was
Termin noch geschafft, ja wir haben Reifen gewechselt
Also zum Beispiel in der Standard-Library
Du hast in Go
3 Varianten
Wie du Variablen zuweisen kannst
Manchmal ist nicht so ganz klar
Was Reference, was nicht
Wo automatisch referenziert wird
Wo du explizit sagen musst Reference
Dann ist das
Konzept mit Maps und
Listen
Ja
Dass du
Dass du beispielsweise
Nicht filtern kannst
Auf Listen und sowas
Das ist ein bisschen roh
Ja in Go
Die Sprache an sich ist cool muss ich sagen
Die ist auch relativ easy zu lesen
Sieht erstmal ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig aus
Weil das ziemlich viele Sonderzeichen, komische Konstrukte hat
Aber weiterhin nicht so schlimm wie C++
Aber wenn man sich mal dran gewöhnt hat geht das eigentlich
Wobei halt
Go hat wie gesagt
Also das größte was mich an Go
Das die Standard-Library so wenig Sachen
Dabei hat
Dass die Go
Maintainer der Meinung sind
Manche Sachen
Die einfach nur praktisch sind
Wären nicht sinnvoll zum Beispiel du kannst
In Go kannst du nicht sagen
So was hier zum Beispiel
Filter
X keine Ahnung
Wenn X größer 2 sowas
Sowas kannst du in Go nicht sagen
In Go musst du eine Schleife machen
Die Go Leute sagen halt
Ja weil Schleife viel einfacher zu lesen ist
Ja wenn du nur C machst
Dann ist ja kein Ding ist ja klar
In C musst du erst halb GitHub installieren
Oder alles selbst basteln
Ne also
Es fehlt mir ein bisschen was
Dann ist manche Sachen
Find ich in Go auch nicht so richtig gut durchdacht
Wie gesagt
Es gibt drei verschiedene Varianten
Variablen zuzuweisen
Die haben dieses Konzept mit Error Codes
Die ich an sich eigentlich ganz gut finde
Also Go hat ja keine Exeptions
Aber Go hat Panic
Was ja im Endeffekt doch
Exeptions sind
Also die machen eigentlich
Alles zum größten Teil
In Go über Error Codes
Aber manchmal hast du dann doch
Panic und Recover und solche Sachen
Es ist ein bisschen undurchdacht
Und was mir halt echt fehlt
Ist Generics
Generics ist eines der geilsten Dinger überhaupt
Und das gibt es halt in Go nicht
Der Cobalt Jebait Train
Ist schon wieder am Start im Chat
Ja Generics kommen angeblich schon
Seit zwei Jahren bald glaube
Aber ich hoffe die kriegen es bald hin
Die Generics kommen immer bald in Go
Aber ich hoffe sie kriegen es hin
Das gibt Go auf jeden Fall einen richtig großen Boost
Weil
Sobald die Generics haben
Kann man auch
Ich will nicht sagen sowas wie Link bauen
Aber sowas ähnliches
Also sprich man kann Listen bauen
Die für alle Datentypen gehen
Mit Filter und Any
Und All und Loops
Und Wear und sonst was
Alles was die Sache ein bisschen einfacher macht
Also dann ist Go gut
Vom Konzept her mag ich das
So was ich jetzt hier auf jeden Fall noch rein nehmen würde
Auch wenn ich kein Fan davon bin
Was auf jeden Fall aber im Business Umfeld
Nicht nur eine Option ist
Sondern in vielen Umfeld fast schon muss
Ist Java
Also ich würde hier eindeutig Rust durch Java ersetzen
Ihr wisst dass ich
Kein Fan bin
Was Java angeht
Aber gerade im Business Umfeld
Ist Java eines der Dinger schlechthin
Und
Mein persönlicher Fall ist ich würde
Anstatt C++ ich würde C Sharp rein nehmen
Das hat ja mit C++ gar nichts zu tun
Die haben sich einfach nur am Namen orientiert
Weil sie gedacht haben
Das kommt den Leuten bekannter vor
Aber C Sharp ist neben Ruby meine absolute Lieblingsprogrammiersprache
Ruby leider
Dead, aber seit Microsoft
.NET open sourced hat
Hat das Ding Fahrt aufgenommen
Und geht ab wie sonst was
Also C Sharp zu lernen
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt
Und C Sharp ist finde ich
Von allen Programmiersprachen
Die hier stehen und die es so gibt
Die universellste Programmiersprache die es gibt
Du kannst in C Sharp
Desktop Programme machen
Server Programme
Web
Geschichten
Mittlerweile läuft es sogar über WebAssembly im Browser
Du kannst zum größten Teil
Lowlevel Sachen machen
Wenn auch nicht komplett
Bootloader in C Sharp programmieren
Aber das ist dann fast eigentlich das einzige
Du kannst mit Unity Spieleentwicklung machen
Du kannst im Prinzip
Du kannst mittlerweile sogar relativ gut
Selfcontent Programme machen
Die sind zwar ein bisschen größer als hier so
So ein Go, Rust oder C Programm
Aber letztendlich ist es
Wurscht wenn man nicht gerade von Microcontrollern
Redet im Prinzip ist es wurscht
Ob dein Programm 10 MB
3 MB
Oder 60 MB ist
Das juckt nicht
So also C Sharp ist auf jeden Fall
Super Geschichte und du kannst wenn du C Sharp gut kannst
Du kannst alles machen
Es gibt eigentlich kein wirkliches
Gebiet wo C Sharp
Komplett versagt
Man muss sagen es gibt einen Bereich
Da ist es vielleicht nicht so
Der absolute Wahnsinn
Oder zwei Bereiche
Das ist Cross-Plattform
GUI Entwicklung Desktop
Fokussiert GUI Entwicklung und
Form-Mobile-Entwicklung
Wobei man sagen muss das geht alles
Ich weiß das es dazu auch Lösungen gibt
Aber
Da würde ich jetzt vielleicht
Nicht unbedingt
Bevorzugen also wenn ich jetzt
Wenn einer zu mir kommt und sagt Max ich brauche eine
Mobile App die überall
Darauf läuft also Android und IOS
Ist ja im Prinzip
Es geht doch ich weiß Tomy
Es ist nicht so mein Fall
Ich muss auch sagen ich habe noch nicht viel mit gemacht
zu mir kommt und sagt ich brauche eine mobile app für ios und android dann würde ich entweder
ja na moment, warte mal, dann kommen wir zu flatter kommen wir gleich dann das erste was ich machen würde ist ich würde ohne scheiß ich
würde eine javascript anwendung machen
Typescript lernen ist auch sinnvoll danach ich würde eine javascript anwendung ich würde eine ionic anwendung machen wahrscheinlich
Weil das hat den vorteil du kannst eine webseite machen du kannst eine pwa machen und du kannst eine mobile app machen alles mehr
Oder weniger in einem schritt das ist einfach unschlagbar
Das nächste mal das nächste was ich machen würde ist
flatter
pwa
progressive web app
also quasi
das hier
Dass man apps quasi dass man webseiten als eigene app installieren kann
Geht mittlerweile auf dem desktop auch, aber mobile ist das eher so eine sache
Wird auch immer besser das support mobile dafür
Also ich ich würde auch nicht direkt direkt ionic nehmen ich habe nur gesagt ionic weil die haben ein unterprojekt von ionic wo du super
Beispielsweise in der vue js app wo du die super verpacken kannst in der native app ohne dass du was ändern musst großartig plus du hast die
Möglichkeit zusätzlich noch ein paar native sachen einzubinden wie gps und sowas
dass ich weiß dass das zu ionic gehört mit ionic selbst habe ich auch nichts gemacht
und das nächste ist wenn einer zu mir sagt max ich brauche eine app die
mobile und desktop läuft
Dann mache ich entweder die gleiche route
Oder ich versuche es mal mit flatter weil flatter ist für mobile entwicklung auf jeden fall absolut top tier
Und in zukunft wird das auf dem desktop auch immer besser
Werden mit flatter 2 haben sie angekündigt sie wollen auch vollgas geben auf dem desktop also ich denke mal
das flatter auf jeden fall wenn man noch mal zwei jahre warten
Eine wirklich super lösung ist für desktop apps und für mobile apps ist es jetzt ja auch schon
Bei firefox geht es aber nur um desktop
Ist da flatter ist da und da ist quasi
Ich ich sag mal übertrieben den javascript die auf dem desktop
Ich sag mal übertrieben den javascript dialekt ist es nicht ich weiß dass es kein javascript dialekt ist aber dat und javascript
dat ist so eine mischung aus
C sharp und javascript type script javascript c sharp so eine mischung mit mit ein bisschen swift dabei vielleicht noch
Maui muss man mal gucken was da rauskommt maui ist ja im prinzip sammarin mit bisschen zeug dabei
und
Gui gui ist eine sache das kriegt microsoft nicht richtig geschissen da ist dazu langsam abgefahren die kriegen es ja die kriegen es ja
Noch nicht mal gebacken bei microsoft für windows ein gescheites ui library framework zur verfügung zu stellen die sind schon ewig dran an ihrem an ihrer
Wie ist das win win ui win ui 3 was im leben nicht rauskommt
oder was irgendwie laufen nicht rauskommt und keine unpackaged apps und unterstützter
Microsoft hat ja selbst realisiert dass uwp kompletter reinfall gewesen ist
objektiv c ist ja im apple umfeld noch ein bisschen angesagt vielleicht gut genug gelabert so viel jetzt zum thema programmiersprache
das andere gehen wir auch noch mal schnell durch
Also hier gebe ich hier stimme ich nicht so ganz zu gerade gerade in diesem part hier stimme ich nicht so ganz zu und bei ruby auch nicht
Da wird was anderes war
ähm
Vielleicht soll ich bei programmiersprachen mir noch was in des des des des ding jazz python go c-shop java
So
Das ist tatsächlich wahr
Das wichtigste ist dass man eine programmiersprache lernt nicht so sehr welche
Es gibt ein paar konzeptionelle unterschiede aber erstmal ist wichtig dass man programmieren lernt
Aber erstmal ist wichtig dass man programmieren lernt
Gut so start-up management ja gut deswegen das würde ich alles unter wir lernen ein bisschen linux und linux auf surfern
Ne das mache ich es auch so nicht als video da überlege ich mir was dazu
Das würde ich eher so wir lernen bisschen linux abhaken ja so
understand different os konzepts process management thread and concurrency das würde ich tatsächlich beim
programmieren auch mit reinhauen sockets
so euer
Networks konzepts ja kann man kann man so unterschreiben ja grade grade ein bisschen networking basics sind tatsächlich nicht verkehrt
Ja man sollte wissen
Was weiß ich was passiert wenn du von rechner rechner b pingst was passiert der lowlevel
mäßig dass sie überhaupt da ankommt man sollte man sollte wissen was weiß ich IP?
und
Warum es überhaupt so viele subnet maß gibt
Ich weiß, das sollte man eigentlich in der Ausbildung lernen, aber ich habe heute morgen auch gerätselt, wie brechen man das noch mal genau und vor allem, wenn es um Netzwerkkonzepte geht, durchaus auch ein bisschen advancedere Sachen, dass man sich mal ein bisschen mit VPN beschäftigt oder wie rute ich Sachen am besten über irgendeinen Tunnel, über einen gesicherten Tunnel nach Azure oder sowas. Da gibt es, da gibt es viel. Man muss es aber nicht übertreiben, man wird kein Netzwerkexperte.
Ja.
Okay, also das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll. I.O. Management, Virtualization, Memory Storage, also vergesst alles, ihr müsst euch nur Virtualisierung angucken und da steht hier gar nicht dabei.
Ach du Scheiße, was kommt denn da noch? What the fuck? Ihr müsst euch zwei Sachen angucken. Ihr müsst euch, der Rest könnt ihr vergessen. Ihr müsst euch zwei Sachen angucken. Ihr müsst euch Virtualisierung angucken und ihr müsst euch auf jeden Fall Containertechnologie angucken.
Also irgendwie von, what the fuck, wartet mal. Okay, also ihr müsst euch auf jeden Fall Virtualisierung und Containertechnologie angucken. Dazu gehört erstmal easy Einstieg, Docker Geschichten. Das hat den Vorteil, da kann man auch einfach lokal rumbasteln.
Ja, Docker, Docker Compose File. Ja. Wenn man, wenn man abenteuerlustig ist, kann man irgendwie, wie heißt das, wie schreibt man das? Minikube, Pi, Kompagnetes Cluster oder irgendwie sowas machen, lokal oder mit irgendwie Cloud, VMs oder sowas.
Ein bisschen, bisschen Container Orchestrierung und so kann man sich auch angucken. Aber ich finde es reicht erstmal, weil das lernt man dann im Umgang. Ich finde es reicht erstmal, wenn man sich prinzipiell darüber klar wird, was ein Container ist.
Weil ich sag ja, du benutzt Docker Stack. Okay, das glaub ich hab ich noch nie verwendet. Was ist denn jetzt Docker? Aha, Swarm ist doch, Swarm ist doch dead.
Exzellent. Was war los? Ich hab Reifen getauscht mit meinem Nachbar. Das hab ich vergessen. Ja, das wusste ich. Kameramann, aber wichtig ist, dass am ersten Mal klar ist, was der Unterschied zwischen der VM und einem Container ist.
Oder allgemein, man sollte wissen, was ein Container ist. Und ich finde ja immer noch, dass Container ein dummes Wort ist. Weil Container, also wenn die Leute erklären wollen, was ein Container ist, in der Regel kommt immer so eine Erklärung in diese Richtung.
Container ist wie eine VM, aber keine VM. Und dann denken sich die Leute, hä, ja wie jetzt? Ist es jetzt eine VM oder ist es keine VM? Und man müsste eigentlich anders anfangen. Man müsste eigentlich komplett anders anfangen.
Und ich finde, dass das Wort Container auch nicht so ganz passend ist, weil das hört sich schon so ein bisschen nach VM an. So eigene, eigene Rechner. Im Prinzip ist ein Container eine Sandbox.
Es gibt keinen wirklich großen Unterschied zwischen, ich starte ein Programm. Also hier, tolles Programm. Ich führ tolles Programm direkt aus. Oder ich würde Docker, ich sag jetzt einfach mal run, was auch immer tolles Programm machen. Um es jetzt mal vereinfacht zu sagen.
Da ist kein großer Unterschied dazwischen. Also das ist erst mal fundamental das gleiche. Das sind zwei Prozesse, die auf deinem Linux laufen. Komplett entgegengesetzt zu dem, was eine VM ist.
Eine VM ist ein Virtualisierungsprozess, der auf deinem Linux läuft, der dann einen kompletten Rechner simuliert und alles was in der VM drinne ist, denkt es läuft auf einem eigenen System. Das hat keine Ahnung von dem Hausbetriebssystem.
Das ist bei Containern komplett anders. Container sind immer ganz normale Prozesse auf deinem Linux System, so wie normal gestartete Programme auch. Der Unterschied zwischen einem Container und einem normal gestarten Programm ist, dass noch ein bisschen Sandbox Mechanik drum herum ist.
Zwar namentlich zwei Sachen, Namespaces und Cgroups. Namespaces ist eine Technik, womit man dem Programm, was man in einem Container in der Sandbox startet, ein paar Dinge vorgaukeln kann, die nicht stimmen.
Was weiß ich, Netzwerk, Hostname, Uhrzeit, solche Dinge, die halt anders sein können im Container wie auf dem Host und Cgroups ist die eigentliche Sandbox, die dafür sorgt, dass der Container manche Dinge nicht darf.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ihr in einem Container seid und ihr habt keine Rechte für USB-Geräte, dann seht ihr vielleicht das USB-Gerät, aber könnt nicht drauf zugreifen. Das ist eine Sandbox, aber es ist im Prinzip immer noch das exakt gleiche Programm, was auf eurem Linux läuft.
Also da ist eigentlich nichts drum herum wie eine VM. Deswegen ist die Erklärung, Container ist wie eine VM, nur ohne VM ist kacke. Deswegen finde ich das Wort auch blöd. Eigentlich sollte man Sandbox sagen.
Sandbox ist, ich glaube unter der Sandbox können sich die meisten Leute was vorstellen und am Container erstmal nicht. Also man sollte eigentlich Sandbox sagen. Und dementsprechend sieht man auch sofort schon den Unterschied. Halber Ted Talk, genau.
Man sieht, deswegen sieht man auch schon sofort den Unterschied zwischen was ich quasi in der Sandbox starte. Im Prinzip mache ich nicht Docker Run, im Prinzip mache ich Sandbox Run, wenn man es mal genau nimmt.
Man sieht ja auch schonmal, man sieht ja auch schonmal den grundsätzlichen, also der Unterschied ist. Jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte. Ah fuck, ich hatte so richtig schnell einen Flow, jetzt hat mich der Chat abgelenkt hier. Der Chat ist wieder schuld.
Wofür ist die Sandbox gut? Wie gesagt, einmal um dem Programm was darin läuft Sachen vor zu gaukeln, die nicht der Realität entsprechen. Zum Beispiel, dass sie ein anderes Netzwerk haben, eine andere Uhrzeit, eine andere Hausnahme oder sowas.
Und dann noch in Form von der Sandbox, dass man auf manche Sachen nicht zugreifen darf. Aber der grundsätzliche Unterschied zwischen einem Container und einem VM ist, also sieht man daran jetzt ja auch schonmal gut, eine VM ist ein komplett simuliertes System und ein Container ist eigentlich nur ein weiteres gestartetes Programm mit ein bisschen Sandbox drum herum.
Dementsprechend braucht ein Container nichts an Zusatzressourcen. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal nichts, weil es im Endeffekt auch so gut wie nichts ist. Du brauchst ein paar Zusatzchecks, du hast einen minimalsten Overhead, weil es im Prinzip nichts anderes ist wie ein weiteres gestartetes Programm auf deinem Hausbetriebssystem.
Das hat aber auch einen Nachteil, wenn du nämlich mehrere Programme laufen lassen willst, die unterschiedliche Anforderungen haben oder unterschiedliche Sachen brauchen, dann geht das nicht.
Also grundsätzlich unterschiedliche Sachen brauchen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du ein Kernel Modul brauchst für ein Programm und das andere braucht ein anderes Kernel Modul oder du brauchst eventuell vielleicht Sachen, die konflikten oder was auch immer, sobald der Host Kernel nicht mehr passt, dann kannst du das vergessen mit Containern, dann musst du eine VM machen.
So und übrigens, wenn es um Overhead zwischen Container und VM geht, es wird oftmals gesagt, CPU ist das Problem, ist das Klausur relevant. Klar, ich bin ungefähr in 45 Minuten fertig, da schreibe ich Arbeit drüber.
Und ich kontrolliere das. Ihr müsst dann alle im Discord auf einen Voice Chat mit Kamera an und ich gucke, dass auch keiner bei euch durchs Bild läuft und euch irgendwas verrät.
Und vorher müssen wir natürlich Corona-Tests machen. Wir wissen ja, in der Schule ist aktuell Corona-Tests angesagt.
So und eine Sache, ich muss mal langsam zum Ende kommen, und eine Sache, die immer angeführt wird, was meiner Meinung nach aber auch nicht stimmt,
die, das Problem bei VMs oder was heißt das Problem, dass das Problem bei VMs ist nicht, dass eine VM langsamer läuft. Das ist überhaupt nicht das Problem.
Also wenn du einen Benchmark machst, wir reden hier von einem CPU Benchmark, nicht Grafikkarten oder sonst was. CPU, also das was man gut in der VM verwenden kann.
Wenn du einen CPU Benchmark machst in einer VM und du machst einen CPU Benchmark in einem Container und du machst einen CPU Benchmark auf einem Host, du siehst keinen Unterschied.
Du hast zwar theoretisch einen Unterschied, klar, und der Unterschied ist theoretisch, dass die VMs theoretisch am langsamsten sein müssten, danach der Container und dann der Host, aber praktisch ist eigentlich kein Unterschied zwischen den drei.
Also der Overhead von VMs ist nicht CPU-mäßig das Problem. CPU ist in VM absolut top. Das Problem bei VMs ist, dass du Speicher brauchst.
Du brauchst in der VM, du brauchst Storage auf der Platte, du musst ein komplett eigenes Betriebssystem laden und du brauchst RAM. Also der eigentliche Overhead bei VMs ist nicht so sehr CPU, sondern hauptsächlich RAM und Storage.
Ja stimmt, nested ist dann wieder was anderes, aber von nested reden wir ja hier an der Stelle nicht. Ja, und das ist RAM und Storage. Note.
Chat. Pepo G. Ja, so sieht es aus. Okay, ich glaube, soll ich weit? Chat, ihr dürft es jetzt entscheiden. Soll ich mich weiter zu dem Thema auslassen oder soll ich endlich anfangen zu programmieren? Bei der Gelegenheit gucke ich gerade nochmal kurz in Chat.
Danke für dein Item, es ist schön, wenn es funktioniert hat. Habe ich nicht gesagt, ich kann dazu nichts sagen? Weiter. Okay, nice. Alles klar. Also, das machen wir weiter.
Okay, also, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Genau, so viel zum Thema Container und VM. Also, man kann sich im Prinzip merken, VM braucht mehr RAM und mehr Storage.
CPU macht eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied und Container ist nicht irgendwie wie eine VM und dann doch keine VM, sondern Container ist eine Sandbox.
Und diese Containergeschichte ist übrigens auch nicht neu, muss man dazu sagen. Und wo wir gerade beim Thema Container sind, Docker hat mit Linux Containern so erstmal gar nichts zu tun. Docker ist ein reines Frontend dafür.
Also, es gibt, wie gesagt, wenn ich sage, ihr startet was im Container, ist es im Prinzip eigentlich sowas wie Sandbox Run. Es ist nicht Docker Run, es ist quasi, wir starten was in der Sandbox.
Das, was Docker macht oder sagen wir mal, ein Programm in der Sandbox starten unter Linux, kann man relativ easy auch selbst programmieren. Das sind ein paar Zeilen über die Linux API.
Ich hab da sogar mal ein Video zugesehen, das sind keine Ahnung, 15 Zeilen C oder C++ oder irgendwas, was Linux kernel API aufrufen kann.
Es gibt Docker für Windows, das ist aber eine VM. Das ist Hyper-V unten drunter.
Kannst du mal kurz erklären, warum C++ gegenüber C-Sharp die bessere Sprache ist? Ja, kurz, null, jebaited. 1. April war gestern.
Genau, und Docker hat damit erstmal gar nicht so viel zu tun. Warum Docker und Container miteinander in Verbindung gebracht wird, ist ganz einfach.
Mit Docker ging der Container-Hype los, weil Docker im Prinzip nichts anderes ist, als ein gutes Frontend zum Bedienen von Linux-Containern.
Also ein gutes Frontend für die Container-Funktionalität im Kernel.
Und die Container-Funktionalität im Kernel, das ist das, was früher so unter LXC gelaufen ist, das ist zum größten Teil Namespaces und Cgroups.
Das ist das, was im Kernel drin ist, und das ist das, was alle Container-Frontends verwenden.
Es ist egal, ob Potman, Kubernetes, Docker, flatcar, Rancher, was auch immer, vollkommen egal.
Das sind alles Frontends für die Funktionalität, die im Linux Kernel ist.
Nämlich Namespaces und Cgroups und ich glaube das Schrägstrich LXC, was auch immer.
Und Docker hat das Ganze quasi nur befeuert, weil es das erste richtig gute und halb generierende Frontend war.
Deswegen denken so viele Leute, dass Linux-Container gleich Docker ist. Nein, Linux-Container hat mit Docker gar nichts zu tun.
Es ging lange vor Docker schon, es gab auch Vorgänger davon und es gibt in anderen Betriebssystemen, in BSD gibt es Jails zum Beispiel.
Früher gab es OpenVZ und solche Geschichten, also Container oder Sandboxes ist nichts Neues.
Aber diese Namespaces und Cgroup-Funktionalität im Linux Kernel plus Docker als Frontend hat halt dafür gesorgt, dass es einen relativ großen Hype gab um das Ganze.
Und deswegen bringen so viele Leute Docker und Container quasi, werfen das in einen Topf.
Sorry, dass ich nochmal nachhage, warum lässt man überhaupt Programme im Container laufen zum Testen?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich eines der ursprünglichen Ideen von Docker gewesen, dass man Sachen reproduzierbar besser testen kann.
Also, du musst dir überlegen, was brauchst du alles, damit dein Programm läuft?
Und das packst du alles quasi in dieses Container-Image mit rein.
Mal angenommen, du hast irgendwie, du hast ein Programm gebastelt, das braucht Library A, B, C, das braucht vielleicht ein Betriebssystem C, Library D, du hast noch irgendwelche,
eventuell irgendwelche, frag mich nicht, du machst ein Exec auf Kommandozeilen, Tools im Hintergrund, die müssen installiert sein vorher, was auch immer.
Also sprich, dein Programm hat gewisse Dependencies, dass es ordentlich funktioniert.
Das ist eigentlich nur ein Stream, ich muss kurz Reifen wechseln dazwischen.
Also sprich, du hast ein paar Dependencies, dass es funktioniert.
So, und eine der ursprünglichen Ideen dieser ganzen Container- und Docker-Geschichte war, dass man Programme reproduzierbar unter gleichen Bedingungen testen kann.
Also sprich, wenn es funktioniert hat bei dir und du hast aber die 20 Abhängigkeiten installiert, die dein Programm braucht,
dann hast du ein Docker-File gemacht, hast dort quasi reingeschrieben, ok, was muss ich alles installieren, dass das Programm läuft und hast es einem geschickt.
Das Docker-File ist, oder generell, das ist im Prinzip ähnlich zu, du hast eine VM mit einem Install-Script.
Ja, du würdest eine VM aufsetzen und dann lässt ein Install-Script laufen, die das System in den Zustand bringt, wie du es brauchst.
Nur das ist halt eine ganze Weile Dauer, du musst den Kram erstmal installieren, dann musst du erstmal das Install-Script laufen lassen, was auch immer.
Docker-File, Docker-Image dauert halt 20 Sekunden, dann ist das Ding runtergeladen und gestartet.
Wenn du das Image schon gezogen hast, dauert es quasi so wie direkt gestartet.
Ja, also der hauptsächliche Grund ursprünglich war tatsächlich mal, nachvollziehbar Programme testen zu können.
So, und dadurch hast du natürlich auch den Vorteil, dass du Sachen konfigurieren kannst und jemand anderem gibst, der das dann bei sich auch ausprobieren kann, unter so weit wie es irgendwie geht, ähnlichen Bedingungen wie bei dir.
Na klar, der hat noch eine andere CPU drin oder irgendwas, was in die Suppe spucken kann, aber im Prinzip, nein, nein, der andere.
Aber im Prinzip kannst du die Sachen reproduzieren, mal wieder aufbauen lassen und daraus ist ein ganzes Ökosystem entstanden.
Die Extremform ist sowas wie Kubernetes, wo du dann quasi so einen Orchestrator hast, wo du dem sagst, ich möchte 5 davon, 5 davon, jetzt möchte ich nicht nur 5, jetzt möchte ich auf einmal 50.
Ich möchte sichergestellt haben, dass nicht mehr als 5 auf der gleichen Hardware laufen, blablabla und das managt das für dich.
Das geht aber auch nur dadurch, weil das reproduzierbar funktioniert und du nicht erstmal in den VM starten musst oder sowas in der Richtung.
Im bisschen kleineren Stil ist das auch ganz praktisch, du kannst zum Beispiel sowas wie Docker Compose verwenden, das ist ein YAML-File, da schreibst du zum Beispiel rein, ich brauche eine MySQL-Datenbank, einen Web-Server und meine Anwendung.
Und ich möchte, dass die Dinger in dieser und dieser Reihenfolge gestartet werden, die Fault-Password für MySQL xy, dann trägst du das ein und das kannst du dann so einfach auf jedem Rechner mit einem Kommando ausführen und dann startet dir quasi dein Test-Environment oder dein Live-Environment, was auch immer, auf jedem x-beliebigen Rechner, wo halt architekturmäßig das läuft.
Das geht einfach schneller.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man das vorher hätte nicht irgendwie auch machen können, es war aber halt aufwendiger.
Und du weißt wie das ist, umso aufwendiger die Sachen sind, umso weniger macht man es.
Man muss übrigens auch nicht alles verkontenerisieren, das ist auch so eine Geschichte, wo finde ich zur Zeit ein bisschen übertrieben wird.
Ich warte noch drauf, bis die Leute ihr LS im Container ausführen.
LS as a Service gibt es dann irgendwann mal.
So nach dem Motto, Nini LS, nee das geht nicht, erstmal Dogger-Container starten.
Da warte ich noch drauf.
Ich hatte auch letztens auf der Arbeit einen, der war unbedingt der Meinung, dass er, kann sogar Wüschel-Studio-Code gewesen sein.
So nach dem Motto, er macht nur noch Container, Container-Only-Workflow hat er erzählt.
Alles klar, alles gut.
Wo ist der Unterschied zu Snap?
Beides sind Frontends für Container, das muss man sich erstmal merken.
Das Handling ist unterschiedlich.
Und Snap versucht halt ein bisschen Package Manager zu sein.
Also Dogger installierst du halt fertige Images und lässt die Sachen drauf laufen und gut ist.
Self-Contained und dein Hausbetriebssystem hat eigentlich gar nichts mit zu tun, weil es ein eigenes Image ist.
Du kannst da auch nicht so ohne Weiteres drauf zugreifen und sonst wie.
Und Snap versucht halt so zu tun, als wäre das Programm in dem Container eigentlich ein Programm, was du hier jetzt easy auf deinem Host ausführen kannst.
Also ich bin ehrlich gesagt kein allzu großer Snap-Fan.
Und was ich bei Ubuntu nicht mag ist, dass sie so Sachen wie Chrome unter der Haube als Snap installieren und so tun, als wäre es aus dem Package Manager ein fertiges Programm.
Alter, jetzt habe ich aber lange gelabert und wir sind nicht mal fertig. Ich mache das jetzt mal im Schnelldurchgang.
Wie installiert man Treiber auf Linux, die als C-Source-File geliefert werden?
Beziehungsweise habe ich falsch gemacht, dass man beim Kompilieren der File meckert, dass init-h nicht kennt.
Du hast wahrscheinlich die Dependencies nicht installiert dafür.
Also wenn du irgendwas inkludierst, was jetzt nicht dort liegt, wo du dein Make oder was auch immer ausführst, dann erwartet er wahrscheinlich, dass irgendeine Library installiert ist.
Dann musst du in deinen Package Manager gehen und das passende Paket installieren.
Zum Beispiel wenn man FFmpeg braucht, dann musst du erstmal, also wenn du FFmpeg Libraries brauchst, musst du erstmal FFmpeg installieren, dass du den Gramm kompilieren kannst.
Ach ja, nicht Ubuntu, sondern Ubuntu natürlich meine ich, Ubuntu.
Ach so Moment, Treiber. Ich dachte es ging um ein fertiges Programm.
Also wenn du Treiber installieren kannst, dann brauchst du in der Regel, da hat er recht, wer hat es denn jetzt hier geschrieben, keine Ahnung, vor einer Stunde oder so.
Dann brauchst du wahrscheinlich die Linux-Header von deinem aktuellen Kernel.
Von deinem aktuellen Kernel, ja.
Musst du mit deinem Package Manager installieren, meistens sowas wie Uptinstall, Linux, Linux-Headers oder Linux-Firmware oder was auch immer.
Musst du gucken, also das ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich von Distro zu Distro.
Aber ja, wenn es ein Treiber ist, musst du auf jeden Fall die Kernel-Header installieren.
Richtig, so sieht es aus.
Genau, so bla bla bla, das haben wir abgehakt, haben wir abgehakt.
Learn about Managing Servers, klar.
Wie gesagt, habe ich ja gesagt, Linux lernen, Operating System, Linux, Unix, Windows.
Unix, ganz knicke.
Also generell auch das ist so cool, dass sein mag, dass du da ein bisschen Auswahl hast.
Du wirst ehrlich gesagt zu 95% mit Linux-Systemen zu tun haben in dem Bereich und vielleicht zu 5% mit irgendwelchen übrig gebliebenen Windows.
Oder im Zweifelsfall auch irgendwelchen Entwickler-Workstations, was auch immer.
Aber es ist 95% Linux, also kann man machen, ist aber nicht wirklich wichtig.
Genauso wie Windows, also Linux, Linux all the way, wenn es um diese Sache geht.
Egal wo, in der Cloud, lokal, sorry nicht lokal, on-prem natürlich, Linux.
So, Suse auf gar keinen Fall, Suse ist der Sack meiner Meinung nach, mag ich null.
Fedora mag ich auch null.
CentOS gibt es nicht mehr in dieser Form, das ist ja quasi dead in der bisherigen Form.
Es gibt eigentlich bloß drei Dinger.
Es gibt Red Hat, das ist im Prinzip das gleiche wie früher CentOS.
Red Hat, Ubuntu, Debian.
Ich persönlich bin ja Ubuntu-Fan, das wisst ihr auf der Arbeit, haben wir hauptsächlich Red Hat.
Debian ist aber auch kein Ding.
Debian, Ubuntu ist jetzt nicht der Wahnsinnsunterschied.
Ubuntu macht komische Sachen, wie beispielsweise YAML-Konfiguration für Netzwerk.
Netzwerk, weiß immer noch nicht, was die geritten hat bei Ubuntu dafür, dass man YAML-Konfig macht für Netzwerk.
Das ist unter Debian schöner, dafür hat Ubuntu einen ein bisschen lockereren Umgang mit Packages.
Ja, da kannst du auch die ein oder anderen Unfree Sachen installieren, ein bisschen modernere Sachen.
Debian ist ja im Prinzip halt schon immer alt, wenn es rauskommt.
Red Hat ist alt mit der Zeit, bringt aber meiner Release es raus.
Ich muss sagen, alles in allem, gesamtpaketmäßig gefällt mir persönlich Ubuntu am besten.
Aber wenn du Ubuntu kannst, kannst du auch Debian und wenn du Debian kannst, kannst du eigentlich auch Ubuntu.
So.
White Crab, was? Das darf man nicht mehr so nennen.
Das ist verboten.
Da ist, da ist die, ist gleich hier die, die Police am Start, Monkathos.
Whitelist!
Ich glaube es geht los. Triggert, alter, triggert.
Wo habe ich denn mein Monkathos?
Ah.
So, gehen wir mal schnell hier rüber.
Learn to live in Terminal. Ja, aber man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Das ist auch ein Tipp, den ich euch geben würde in der Richtung, übertreibt sich.
Es gibt ganz viele, gerade auf YouTube, ich nenne es mal Gurus, die dir erzählen, so wie sie das machen, ist The Way.
Der einzige Way, den es gibt, ist, so wie es euch, für euch am angenehmsten ist.
Also ich persönlich nutze auch gern das Terminal und mache da viel drüber.
Gerade wenn es was ist, was man vielleicht auch mal automatisch laufen lassen will, aber ich würde nicht im Traum drauf, auf die Idee kommen, quasi alles nur noch in Wim zu machen oder in Emacs.
Und ganz Hardcore-Varianten, dann verwenden ja sogar einen Textbrowser oder einen Browser mit Wimkeys oder sonst was.
Oder sagen, Leute, steckt die Maus ab, ihr dürft die Maus nicht mehr benutzen, dass ihr gut im Terminal werdet.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach alles Schwachsinn.
Man sollte im Terminal gut klarkommen, man sollte sich so die Standard-Shortcuts angucken, man sollte wissen, wie man in Wim bedient.
Ich persönlich komme mit Wim viel besser klar als mit Nano.
Nano ist, finde ich, immer nervig, wenn da einer Nano aufmacht, aber es ist alles letztendlich Geschmackssache.
Aber es macht meiner Meinung nach keinen Sinn, Wim in irgendwie eine JavaScript oder C-Sharp-IDE oder sowas umzubauen.
Da nehme ich passende Tools für.
Also die Stärken von Wim liegen meiner Meinung nach in einem schnellen, geschwinden, Kommandozeilen-Texteditor.
Und nicht so sehr im Aufbau mit 30 Milliarden Plugins.
Man kann auch VS Code mit Wim-Extension benutzen, wobei ich das nicht mag.
So, und das nächste ist, wenn ihr jemand habt, der euch dann erzählt, ja, immer die Finger auf der Home-Row und nicht die Maus benutzen, es ist 2021.
Man benutzt 60% der Zeit, auch wenn man am Programmieren ist, einen Browser, um Dinger nachzugucken.
Und einen Browser zu bedienen ohne Maus geht schlicht und ergreifend nicht richtig.
Also es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, absichtlich auf die Maus zu verzichten.
Ihr steigert eure Effizienz am Rechner definitiv mehr dadurch, wenn ihr ordentliches Aiming habt hier auf eurem Browser, als wenn ihr ein paar Millisekunden in Wim schneller seid.
Zumal man ja auch sagen muss, dass man 90% der Zeit, wenn man Sachen programmiert, nicht Hacker-Man tippt, sondern überlegt.
Weil die Vorstellung, dass man komplizierte Sachen in dieser Geschwindigkeit programmiert, haben vielleicht irgendwelche Fernsehsendungen oder so, aber die Realität ist es halt nicht.
In Wirklichkeit, wisst ihr wie die Realität aussieht? Die Realität ist eigentlich, okay, lass mal das kurz ausprobieren.
Okay, ausführen, gucken, ob das Ganze funktioniert. Ah, okay, scheint zu funktionieren. Machen wir mal hier.
Ah, Mist, wie ist der Aufruf? Nochmal C++, AP, Blah, Pointer, dumm. Aha, ist der Goverflow, okay, okay, Copy-Paste.
Ja, mal gucken, ob das damit geht. Schreiben wir das mal ein bisschen um. Okay, und jetzt. So, so läuft das ja normalerweise, realistisch betrachtet, ja.
Und das hat damit nichts zu tun. Und dementsprechend, wenn ihr schnell seid, einen guten Browser bedienen könnt, ist das auch wichtig.
Also nicht zu sehr übertreiben mit Terminal-Hackermann, ja. Stack-Overflow-Triffen-Development, genau.
So, T-marks-Lernen ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, sinnvoller als Screen zu lernen. Was machst du gerade? Ich Reakte.
Ich lasse mich zu dieser Roadmap aus, weil mich jemand gefragt hat. Also das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll. Also T-marks-Lernen ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Also ich muss sagen, das war eines der sinnvollsten Investitionen überhaupt, dass ich T-marks lernen konnte, dass ich T-marks gelernt habe.
Das hilft ungemein. Natürlich, man kann auch einfach mehrere Terminals aufmachen, wenn man sowas machen will.
Aber, gerade wenn man per SSH auf einem Server ist, ist T-marks praktisch und T-marks schützt euch halt davor, die Session zu verlieren.
Also sprich, wenn ihr detached werdet vom Server und ihr habt was laufen im Hintergrund und die Verbindung zum Server crasht bei euch.
Und, ne, also Verbindung zum Server ist jetzt gecrashed und ihr lockt euch neu ein, dann könnt ihr euch einfach neu attachen aufs T-marks und es ist immer noch da.
Excellent.
Bäm, Terminal geschlossen und zack, das ganze ist immer noch da.
So, also das ist auf jeden Fall eine äußerst coole Geschichte. Also T-marks lernen lohnt sich definitiv. Das ist wirklich richtig huge und ist gar nicht so schwierig.
So, Bash Scripting auf jeden Fall, Vim, Nano, PowerShell, Emacs, bisschen Vim Navigation reicht ehrlich gesagt. Rest kannst du knicken, PowerShell ist eh Paints Champ.
Text Manipulation Tools, gebe ich ihm voll und ganz recht. Shell Scripting, trotz hier Python Geschichten und so, kommste eigentlich immer noch nicht drum herum.
Process Monitoring, gebe ich ihm auch recht. Ja, Networking, so zu gucken wie man mal Pakete mitschneidet und so, das ist auf jeden Fall auch.
So, das OSI Modell, ja da hab ich jetzt noch drauf gewartet.
Network Security, klar, HTTP, HTTPS, na FTP, FTP könnt ihr streichen. FTP ist...
Tja.
Juckt eigentlich keinen mehr. Ich war vor 10 Jahren vielleicht zuletzt über FTP Server eingeloggt.
SSL, TLS auf jeden Fall, SSH, ja also die wichtigsten Sachen davon im Bereich Administration oder beziehungsweise auch hier im Linux Bereich ist SSH und SSH Port Weiterleitung.
Äh, ja, passt, gut, Web Server, ja, ja, ja, ist okay. EES meinetwegen, Nginx, würde ich tatsächlich genauso sagen, meine Pers...
Tomcat ist kein klassischer Web Server eigentlich. Ich würde sagen Nginx und Cutty, Cutty zum Einstieg ist eine super Sache, weil easy zu konfigurieren.
Äh, ich geb mein Zen-Fehler zu ab. Danach programmieren wir weiter.
Learn Infrastructure as Code, auf jeden Fall, das ist das erste was ich gesagt hab, was dazu gehört.
Äh, Docker LXD hatten wir auch schon, ja, bla, sonst wie.
Ich würde erstmal die Basics lernen, bevor ich hier an Container Orchestration gehe.
Infrastructure Provision in Terraform, das würde ich mir auch erst angucken in Zusammenhang mit dem hier.
Vorher würde ich mir die wirklich mal die einfachen Sachen angucken hier zum Einstieg und sich ein bisschen rantasten hier, ja.
Ich würde mir Ansible raussuchen und ich würde mir Docker raussuchen.
Und da ein bisschen rumbasteln, Docker Compose, sonst wie was.
Ähm, nicht agil genug, ja, Agile alles.
Cloud Providers, wie gesagt, ich hab mein Kram alles bei Hetzner.
AWS, ja, da müsst ihr wissen was wichtig ist, ich persönlich hier bin ja in der Azure-Richtung am Start, aber da müsst ihr wissen was wichtig ist.
Deployment und Continuous Integration Tools, hab ich ja schon erzählt vorhin.
Infrastructure Monitoring, ganz ehrlich, da geb ich ihm voll und ganz recht.
Prometheus, Grafana, beste Kombi.
Es ist vielleicht nicht für alles so gut geeignet, wie so die klassischen Sachen beim Zappix, aber Prometheus, Grafana ist easy.
Und es gibt ein richtig großes Ökosystem, wo man fast alles mittlerweile mitmachen kann.
Da kann ich nicht viel zu sagen.
Ah, gut, fertig, reacted.
Ja, und das ist nochmal so zur Untermauung, das ist im Prinzip das, was ich vorhin auch gesagt hab.
Python ist mit so die angesagteste und beliebteste Programmiersprache, gerade wenn es um AI-Sachen geht.
JavaScript, weil es Web ist, ist halt vorne. Danach Java, Go und C-Sharp ist auch mittlerweile noch relativ weit vorne.
Wir können ja mal 2000 gucken, ob man das ganze Jahr zusammenfassen kann, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht nicht.
Ja, weil C-Sharp ist die letzten Jahre ganz schön gestiegen.
Ja, guck, oder auch nicht.
Hier wurde es open sourced, hier wurde es open sourced und hier ist...
Okay, ich hätte eigentlich schon gedacht, dass es deutlich mehr gestiegen ist.
Na, ist es ja auch.
Von Windows Only Days hier vorne, zu jetzt quasi da, na gut.
Ruby ist im Zuwachs? Nee, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Wo ist Ruby?
Leute, Leute, Chat, wie spricht man Ruby richtig aus? Ihr wisst's, oder? Der Chat weiß es.
Guck mal Ruby, wie es runtergeht. Chat, wie spricht man Ruby richtig aus?
Was Java da vorne macht, klar. Java ist im Enterprise Umfeld der Shit.
Und wisst ihr, woran das noch liegt, dass Java so weit vorne ist?
Wer weiß es?
Chat ist clever.
An den Chinesen, genau. Android vielleicht auch zum Teil, aber gerade die Chinesen sind komplette Java-Fans.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mit den Chinesen los ist, aber wir wissen ja, die Chinesen haben es mit Menschenrechten eh nicht so.
Da liegt Java halt nahe.
Ja, die Chinesen stehen unglaublich auf Java.
Hier Leute, ich muss mal kurz Licht anschalten.
Wobei, wenn ich sage, ich muss kurz Licht anschalten, dann heißt es, ich muss den Browser, den Home Assistant aufmachen und kurz auf den Knopf drücken, dass es Licht angeht. So, Licht ist an.
Die Chinesen haben auf GitHub auch immer mehr C++. Ja, ich sag ja, die haben es mit Menschenrechten nicht so.
Ok Leute, ich bin jetzt schon wieder da, hab eineinhalb Stunden geschwätzt und wisst ihr, wie viel Zeilen wir schon programmiert haben?
Nichts.
Exzellent.
Ok, kommen wir mal zur Sache.
Hatte JavaScript fünf Jahre lang auf meinem PC nicht installiert?
Doch, du hattest garantiert JavaScript auf deinem PC installiert, aber 1000%ig hattest du JavaScript auf deinem PC drauf.
Oder hast du nicht im Internet gesurft?
Jeder Browser bringt JavaScript mit.
Das ist aber echt eine gute Idee.
Wie würdest du das alles lernen? Hast du Tipps mit den Sachen anfangen, die einem Spaß machen, einen interessieren und alles andere ignorieren?
Kurse mögen auch schon sinnvoll sein, aber ich guck mir gerne, ich guck mir gerne, ähm, Talks und, und, äh, was soll ich sagen?
Talks von Konferenzen und den offiziellen Content von den jeweiligen Herstellern an.
Ich guck mir beispielsweise gerne den Microsoft Content an, wenn es um.NET geht. Das ist immer ganz gut gemacht.
Man muss aber halt schon meistens ein bisschen Vorkenntnisse haben.
Oh, mir kraut's davor.
Das ist dann nicht gut.
Oh, mir kraut's davor. Das ist dann nicht Kobold, sondern Kobold.
Oder wenn sie Schnee ist, die schneen mal eine Schobold raus.
Kennst du Lean? Das ist irgendeine Agilitätsgeschichte, ne? Für die coolen, die Agile Leute sind auch Lean.
Lean ist doch auch irgendeine, so eine, so eine Agile Prozessgeschichte.
So, ok, ähm, jetzt machen wir weiter.
Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Also, wir können den Sensor auslesen, also den da, immer noch, das geht immer noch um den Sensor. Wir haben ja in den letzten Streams nichts gemacht, außer, dass ich sinnlos rumgelabert hab.
Die Chinesen haben den eigenen Engine X.
Ihr wundert mich nicht.
Die Chinesen haben schon alles geforkt, was man forken kann.
So, also wir machen jetzt an der Stelle weiter. Was wir vorhin im Stream hingebracht haben ist, dass wir die, ja du hast nichts verpasst, Enrixl, ich hab gerade geschwätzt eineinhalb Stunden und jetzt fangen wir wieder an.
Also, wir haben kein Monka-Fork mehr, haben wir das nur, haben wir das nur im, ah das haben wir nur im Discord, oder? Lul.
So, also was wir jetzt geschafft haben, ist von diesem Sensor, wir können abfragen, ähm, Temperatur, Licht und, ähm, also Helligkeit, Helligkeit in Lux, Temperatur in Celsius, also nicht in Fahrenheit oder in irgendwelchen anderen Krokona-Krokodilen.
Also, also das ist jetzt schon ziemlich, ziemlich gut.
licht
und
also helligkeit helligkeit in lux
Temperatur in Celsius also nicht in Fahrenheit oder irgendwelchen anderen
Kokona Kokona Einheiten
und
Wir können Batterie wir können Batterie ab abfragen so und der witz ist wir
Fragen von diesem sensor nichts ab außer der Batterie der sensor broadcasted alle 30 Sekunden
Sekunden licht aktuell aktuell licht und aktuell Temperatur das greifen wir einfach nur ab dass wir nicht unnötig Batterie kosten
also nicht unnötig Batterie
Drainen und alle fünf stunden alle fünf stunden updaten wir den sensor
Ja alle fünf stunden updaten mit dem sensor also wer schon immer mal wissen wollte was fünf stunden in in mikrosekunden sind
Der weiß es jetzt 18 Milliarden mikrosekunden ist sind fünf stunden
Peppo g leute wird nachher auch abgefragt
Das ist das ist die frage für nubs
Ihr kennt es ja lehrer machen das immer so sie machen immer so ein paar easy easy questions rein
Dass sie nubs auch ein paar punkte bekommen das ist später die frage die ich dann auch mache
was nicht pep o g
Peppo g natürlich pep o g das ist die frage die ich nachher auch dann stellen werde hier was sind fünf stunden in mikrosekunden
So
Das funktioniert alles deswegen minimiere ich das ich wollte jetzt den ganzen krempel an mein home assistant per mqtt schicken also sprich
Das ist mein test home assistant
Wo wir letztens mal auch den stromverbrauch versucht haben
rein zu pumpen das ist mein test home assistant wir gucken jetzt dass wir das ganze per mqtt an den home assistant geschickt bekommen
Per mqtt
Die die twitch viewer
Spacken auch ganz schön rum gerade oder wenn ich mir das hier angucke eben war es 130 jetzt in 234 ohne host
twitch please
Was ist da los?
Was ist da los wieder? Ich glaube es war die ganze zeit schon so was in dem dreh
Nun das twitch wieder das nicht gecheckt hat
Weil vorher war es auch schon 200 und auf einmal ist es instant gejobbed auf 130 jetzt wieder hoch und weiß nicht viewbots
So da sind wir vorher stehen geblieben wir sind stehen geblieben bein wir connect
Per wi-fi und wir wollen den kram selbst machen wir connecten uns per wi-fi
zum
Wlan haben wir schon gemacht guck wenn ich den controller mal resetter mit dem knopf dann sieht man connecting wi-fi bla bla bla bla
ip
1221 68 60 15 114
Ah gut
Nicht zu sagen
exzellent
Warum gibt es eigentlich?
eigentlich nicht
äh
Printeln das wäre dann warum gibt es nicht sowas das wäre dann
Newline text und noch mal newline hinten dran printen
Sowas sollte mal erfunden werden ich bin bestimmt nicht der einzige der sowas schon mal sich überlegt hat
Okay, ich bin ich der einzig das ich das schon überlegt hat
Aber nicht wie leute guckt mal vier ergebnisse auf google sonst nix
Gleich guitar projekt erstellen
Ergebnisse auf google sonst nix gleich guitar projekt erstellen printeln
Okay also weiter im text
Ich wollte das ganze per mqtt an mein home assistant schicken
Also wir verbinden uns per wlan passt wir geben die ip aus passt auch so das heißt jetzt wird's big brain nämlich
Wenn man per home assistant per mqtt was schicken will dann ist das format ein bisschen
Paintschamp ich zeige euch das mal
Es gibt nämlich zwei verschiedene varianten wie man das machen kann
Also wie gesagt home assistant ist hier die heim automatisierungslösung die ich verwende
Und man kann dort über mqtt geräte anlegen lassen und das versuche ich jetzt mal also ich weiß wie es geht also ich kann das copy pasten
Also sprich wir lesen jetzt hier die sensoren aus übertragen die da ein home assistant dass ich dass ich dort was mit anfangen kann
Ja, dass ich dort im dashboard machen kann oder was auch immer also die werte übertragen wir die heim automatisierung so es die haben so einen die haben so einen
So ein eigenes protokoll wie man geräte anlegt
Das sieht ungefähr so aus ja man muss erst mal sagen was für ein gerät man anlegt
Dann darf dann kann man ihm sagen wie das heißen soll
Und dann muss man ihm sagen was das für ein gerät ist in dem fall ist es in motion detection
Es gibt auch noch einen energie monitor oder was auch immer man kann noch einen namen vergeben und man kann ihm sagen wo er in zukunft den
Aktuellen status zu dem gerät findet das ist
Allerdings nicht die ganze wahrheit es gibt noch die neuere variant die hier gar nicht drinne steht
In dieser doku man kann nicht nur einzelne sensoren anlegen über über mqtt also das wäre zum beispiel ein einzelner sensor
Zum beispiel hier diesen sensor haben wir haben das letzte mal von hand angelegt über mqtt hier sensor watt schämen first floor energy
Das war wo ich mein stromzähler ausleser getestet habe
Das ist das ist die halbe wahrheit es gibt eine neuere variant die ist viel besser die ist aber ein bisschen komplizierter in
Ist auch jason was man hinschicken muss aber ist ein bisschen komplizierter und zwar
Man kann ein komplettes gerät erstellen lassen
Über über mqtt im home assistant das steht als komplettes gerät da drinne mit unterschiedlichen sensoren das heißt ich weiß auch
Zu welchem gerät dieser sensor gehört und das ist richtig big brain und das ist das wie es alle aktuellen integrationen machen
Und wie ich das auch machen will ich weiß auch wie es bei mqtt ist
Und wie ich das auch machen will ich weiß auch wie es prinzipiell funktioniert weil ich habe das schon mal gemacht das muss ich jetzt nebenbei abgucken
so
Was soll das programm erzielen das erzielt schon folgendes ich habe einen sensor für
bodenfeuchtigkeit temperatur und lichteinstrahlung
Und da lese ich aktuell die werte draus aus wobei ich die werte nicht auslese
Sondern der sensor broadcast die werte alle 30 sekunden und ich schneide die über bluetooth low energy low energy bluetooth mit
Das einzige was ich alle fünf stunden querier von jedem gerät ist die ist der batterie der batterie stand ja du siehst auch hier das gerät
broadcasted
munter vor sich hin
Der scan hängt schon wieder
scan startet warum wie wie kann das sein dass der scan startet und der scan nicht aufhört das ist doch ein bug oder
Oder wollte mich rollen ich habe kein bock dass das ding dass das ding crasht
Guck mal der scan hängt schon wieder dabei dabei soll der einfacher der soll nach fünf sekunden ausgehen
Nach fünf sekunden ausgehen
Was mal so vielleicht geht es dann besser
Was soll dadurch ermöglicht so habe ich ja ganz vergessen das ding kommt in kühlschrank
Anhand dem licht sensor erkenne ich ob ich die tür aufgelassen habe zumindest so weit dass es licht noch angeht
Und anhand der temperatur erkenne ich ob der kühlschrank irgendwelche probleme hat mein kühlschrank hat ein paar probleme da macht manchmal komische geräusche
Den muss man manchmal rebooten dass er richtig funktioniert das heißt ich habe meine bedenken er gibt der nix den geist auf und ich kriege es nicht
richtig mit
An anderer denkbarer fall wäre auch keine ahnung man hat
Stromprobleme oder irgendwie sonst wie was verstopft ist kaputt was auch immer man bekommt mit wenn der kühlschrank weil das ist halt
Low energy und wireless und
Da bekomme ich das quasi mit wenn man kühlschrank probleme hat und
Natürlich man lernt wie es geht das natürlich auch eine wichtige geschichte
So
Dann würde ich sagen nehmen wir mal los also
Das eigentlich auslesen funktioniert was der macht ist folgendes der scan nach geräten die sich melden wenn sich ein gerät also
Der scan nach einem nach einem sensor nach einer art dieser sensoren und wenn er einen sensor gesehen hat
Dann legt er eine neue neue sensor objekt an und speichert das hier in der map drinne
Und update ist dann sobald hier neue neue werte neue werte reinkommen
Und dann fragt er alle fünf stunden einmal den batteriestatus aktiv ab jetzt habe ich aber alles minimiert weil wir das nicht brauchen
so und jetzt
Aber mal verbindung zum mqtt server
Das ist ein minimaler mqtt rapper den ich selbst gebaut habe weil das so
Ja
It's it's mqtt weil das so pains champig ist das eingebaute mqtt zu verwenden von dem
Espressif framework ja aber das ist wirklich nicht großartig kompliziert hier gibt es zwei metoden publish eine message
Macht das nicht probleme weil du mehrere hast ja das deswegen mache ich es auch so wie ich es mache guck mal
Der scannt der scannt nach geräten so der findet ein gerät was er dann macht ist
Was er dann macht moment
Sobald ein gerät gefunden hat nicht immer noch am basteln schon wieder ich muss zwischendurch weg reifen wechsel ich habe jetzt erst wieder
angefangen vor zehn minuten ich bin zwar schon länger ordn aber davor habe ich sinnlos rumgeschwätzt
So und sobald ein gerät gefunden hat speichert das in dieser in dieser map drin das heißt wenn ein zweites gerät findet speichert das da auch
Drinne das geht mit beliebig vielen geräten bis der ram von dem gerät alle bis der ram vom controller alles
So und jetzt wollen wir das ganze mal per mqtt an homosystem zu schicken zur wlan verbindung funktioniert schon mal
Das heißt wir legen jetzt mal ein mqtt server objekt an machen wir das hinten mal weg
Also
Helper it's
Hallo
Ich sollte das mal in namespace stecken das habe ich nämlich normalerweise
Namespace namespace ist ein richtig richtiger pains champ in c++ sag es euch
Helper
It's mqtt so und wir brauchen den server
User und ein password also server ist mqtt doppelt punkt doppelt slash
192 168
So ich bin jetzt gar nicht sicher ob ich da port mit angehen musste oder nicht wie habe ich das noch mal gebastelt
Brauche ich ein port ne default port nimmt da standardmäßig ok alles klar brauche ich kein port und ich brauche nicht mehr
MQTT davor zu schreiben weil er das automatisch macht
So
Dann brauche ich ein password. Ich glaube ich atme 1 2 3 4 5 6 so wie ich mich kennen
So wie ich mich kenn habe ich dann nix sinnvolles für vergeben
Atmen 1 2 3 4 5 6 ja wer hätte denn was anderes erwarten können
War klar
Moin dm drill 40
exzellent so jetzt sollte er sich dahin verconnecten und jetzt müsste ich sachen schicken können
probieren wir das mal aus probieren wir das mal aus sub wir machen da wir lauschen mal an allem
der wattchamp mehr ist da nicht drinnen außer das was wir das letzte mal schon geschickt haben so
wir publishen jetzt einfach testweise meine message und gucken ob das funktioniert
machen wir einfach hier mqtt publish topic keckw message 12345 oder so
so und das sollte jetzt eigentlich hier gleich rauskommen ach fuck ne das funktioniert ja nicht
ich habe den exis point umgestöpselt ich habe den exis point in in das in das wlan wlan gesteckt
und davon habe ich jetzt ja keinen zukunft mehr auf die kiste chat seid ihr schon drinnen ja
okay äußerst interessant dass der keine fehlermeldung schmeißt wenn er nicht
connecten kann ah doch hier guck mal mqtt timeout ok alles gut funktioniert nicht
ich muss mal kurz eine feierball freischaltung machen auf dem zweiten bildschirm auf die kiste
was habe ich gesagt 1 2 1 6 8 2 punkt 100 300 ja hier ok kurz kurz freischaltung machen zack
mqtt destination 2 1 3 9
so
protokoll tcp destination port 1883 was ist die fault mqtt 1883 oder
ja ok
ok destination address absender wlan hier xy
2 1 3 9 ok es sollte jetzt funktionieren
guck mal feierball freischaltung gemacht schon funktioniert
gut also ich kann sachen publishen gut jetzt muss ich noch einbauen dass der was
heißt nur noch nur noch einbauen dass der home assistant kompatible
sensordaten published ok das funktioniert also wie man das macht kann ich euch zeigen
das copy paste ich mir aber mal oder ich gucke mir das zumindest ab wie das funktioniert also
wir brauchen zwei metoden die zwei zwei funktionen jetzt an der chat wir wissen ja wir schreiben
nach einer arbeit darüber was ist der unterschied zwischen einer methode und einer funktion oh das
dauert schon zu lang das gibt abzüge ich sage es euch ist das gleiche fast es ist nicht wirklich
viel unterschied im prinzip ist es das gleiche mit einem einzigen unterschied ja ja richtig
captain peng kennt sich aus exzellent exzellent nee was auch immer falsches emote aber ja das
ist richtig also metoden sind funktionen innerhalb von der klasse oder funktionen die bestandteil
von einer klasse sind sind metoden warum auch immer man das so genannt hat keine ahnung
es haben sich mal irgendwelche big brain leute ausgedacht das ist aber so ist es nicht innerhalb
von objekten korrekt korrekt jetzt wird es aber jetzt wird aber ganz ganz genau ja also
wir brauchen zwei sachen und zwar wir brauchen einmal was mqtt publish announce und wir brauchen
sowas in der richtung wie mqtt publish value so weil man muss man muss dass man home assistant
compatible sensor daten veröffentlichen kann sodass das dann hier drinne steht muss man
das in zwei schritten machen man muss einmal das gerät anlegen von dem das gesendet wird
dass es als erkannt wird diese sensor daten kommen alle vom gleichen gerät drin für
neun stange für den sub und dann muss man regelmäßig neue werte publishen so nachdem
wir da jetzt jason sachen machen müssen werde ich mal eine library hinzufügen nämlich es
gibt eine das will einfach nicht mehr es hat gedacht kein bock nur mal sicherstellen dass
es auch weg ist hat es kann man visual studio geupdatet gut nice sehr gut excellent hast
du eigentlich auch kontakt mit fedor all of cookies wir hatten nie großartig kontakt so
mal ganz vereinzelt aber nie habe ich in letzter zeit habe ich nicht wirklich mit ihm gesprochen
also schon ewig her so sind wir stehen geblieben wir wollen sensor daten publishen genau weil
dann hatten wir den vorteil dass das hier als einzelnes gerät auftaucht das heißt
ich habe da ein gerät hier drin stehen nämlich den cool champ in dem fall warum haben wir
den eigentlich cool champ genannt weil es für kühlschrank ist der cool champ so ich
brauche eine library für jason kram weil jason zu schreiben mit c++ string manipulation
es sagt deswegen nehmen wir einfach das hier hinzufügen in den cool champ gut und jetzt
können wir nämlich anfangen also wir müssen jetzt erstmal ankündigen wenn es einen neuen
sensor gibt zu welchem gerät das ganze gehört da muss ich mir jetzt ein paar sachen copy
pasten und zwar wir brauchen einmal den name von dem für das gerät beziehungsweise nicht
für das gerät wir brauchen einen namen für den sensor das projekt hieß doch anfangs
noch flora champ ja kann sein aber der chat hat gesagt ich soll uns unbedingt cool champ
ich habe das halt auch mal gemacht ja ich weiß ich weiß es ist meistens keine gute
idee auf den chat zu hören aber in dem fall fand ich cool champ lustiger so also wir brauchen
dann ein name für den sensor wenn man den ankündigen wir brauchen eine device class
das ist in home assistant so das habe ich glaube ich vorher schon gezeigt dass es das
home assistant weiß wie er das ganze darstellen soll da gibt es dann so sachen wie batteriestatus
energie luftfeuchtigkeit licht signalstärke und so ich muss ihm also sagen was das ist
und ich muss ihm sagen welche einheit das ganze hat so und jetzt machen wir ein bisschen
jason magic das copy paste das copy paste ich mir jetzt hier an der stelle einfach mal also
man braucht einen state topic das ist das was home assistant sagt unter welchem mqtt
fahrt er dann den neuen status für den jeweiligen sensor findet wie willst du den sensor anbinden
easy das alles schon fertig ich schmeiß dieses ding im kühlschrank ja ich krieg ich brauche
kein wlan signal das ist low energy bluetooth allerdings ist das beides 2,4 gigahertz aber
wir haben es ausprobiert es geht ohne problem aus dem kühlschrank raus funktioniert aber
schon ausprobiert was ist die reichweite von dem teil naja ich bin so ungefähr würde
ich mal sagen fünf meter vielleicht weg oder so viel weiter wird es nicht gehen funktioniert
in home assistant dann die mqtt autodiscovery genau deswegen das programmieren wir gerade
dass die autodiscovery funktioniert inklusive neustart überleben und dass alles vom dass
man sieht dass alles vom gleichen gerät kommt also man muss erstmal man braucht eine name
für den sensor ja also sowas wie sowas wie cool champ dann mech oder so von dem jeweiligen
gerät ok also man braucht eine name für den für den jeweiligen sensor dann braucht man
als nächstes ein identifier und identifier müssen wir ein bisschen mehr muss man bisschen
big brainiger machen jetzt fragt ihr euch natürlich was ist der unterschied zwischen
dem state topic und dem identifier der unterschied ist dass der identifier einheitlich gleich
sein muss für alle sensoren von der gleichen hardware nur dann werden die zusammengefasst
zu hier in der config quasi eine hardware hat 20 sensoren das heißt der identifier
muss für alle muss für alle sensoren die ich hier anlege gleich sein also sprich der
identifier ist quasi das was die hardware identifiziert wo die sensoren dran hängen
jetzt mal sinnbildlich die hängen nicht wirklich da dran aber die hardware die sensoren meldet
so nennen wir es mal identifier so und dann brauchen wir also jetzt müssen wir uns überlegen
wie setzen wir das zusammen dass das das das unic ist ja also das sprich dass alle geräte
die die sich die sich melden also sprich wenn ich mal ein weiteres projekt habe der watt
champ zum beispiel ist auch drin dass sie einheitliche namen haben und ich habe mich
jetzt für folgendes entschieden ich mache erst mal ein projektname rein in dem fall
ist es der cool champ cool champ underscore bei ja so dann schreibe ich rein das mache ich
übrigens das habe ich beim watt champ auch so gemacht dass ich es erkenne esp 32 habe
ich schreibe noch die plattform rein underscore beide weil ich könnte den underscore ohne
problem auch hier hin machen underscore bin das nächste mal für einen mikrowellensensor
sowas gibt es es gibt ultraschall sensor mikrowellensensor keine ahnung ob sowas gibt aber ultraschall
sensoren gibt es ist für reichweitenmessung ganz gut so dann jetzt jetzt kommt ein bisschen
jetzt kommt ein bisschen magic und zwar wir nehmen esp mech so also die bezeichnung für
unsere hardware ist immer projektname hardware name und die netzwerk mech vom controller
das bedeutet diese kombination ist ziemlich garantiert weltweit unic und ich muss mir
keine gedanken machen bei weiteren projekten dass ich da irgendwie mal doppelte sachen
bekomme so dann brauchen wir als nächstes jeder sensor braucht eine eigene id warum
das neben einem eigenen topic noch mal eine eigene id braucht weiß ich nicht aber home
assistant sagt dass man das braucht kann man das hier nehmen also dies unic sensor id
ist quasi der name vom sensor plus der identifier von der hardware genau so als nächstes braucht
man ein availability topic das ist das was home assistant sagt ob das gerät offline
oder online ist ohne funktioniert es btw nicht ich finde es ein bisschen schade dass
sie das schlecht dokumentiert haben man kommt man findet da irgendwie nicht so viel so danach
braucht man ein config topic das ist auch magic das ist jetzt nicht für den sensor
state sondern das ist zum einmaligen anlegen von diesem sensor weil so und jetzt kommt
jason gedöns ich copy paste mir das jetzt einfach mal und dann erkläre ich was es macht
weil ich habe das schon mal gemacht ich kriege das jetzt nicht noch mal hier zusammen gereimt
und ich das kopiere also wir brauchen ein jason dokument das ist das wird eine funktion stink
normale funktion man könnte das auch schön kapseln in irgendeiner klasse wir legen den
jason dokument an was ich übrigens noch mal tun muss dass es funktioniert
und wie nur jason perfekt jetzt sollte das eigentlich erkennen hoffe ich mal oder auch
nicht hat er erkannt exzellent so jason dokument da legen wir den neuen key an availability
ich werde es übrigens gleich mal unten drunter dann printen dass man sieht wie das wie das
jason aussieht was ich da hinschicke key availability und da drinne legen wir neues objekt an also
sprich das ist dann quasi sowas hier neues objekt und da drinne steht dann availability
und das ist wiederum ein eigenes jason array weil das halt so aussehen muss wie es aussieht
und da legen wir objekt an und das brauchen ein topic und dann verweisen wir auf dieses
topic den anderen kram kopiere ich jetzt auch einfach mal
das nächste ist was die hardware identifiziert das muss überall gleich sein also da kann
ich mir ausdenken aber der identifier muss überall gleich sein
dann lege ich den sensor somit an habe ich das nicht unit genannt überhaupt geht das
nicht unit ist undefined ach ich hab keck wait unit alter ich kann ja mal schreiben string
wind so da muss man auch die plattform setzen über das das ganze gemeldet wird ok so und
als letztes muss man diese zwei sachen publishen habe ich oben mqtt angelegt jawoll als am ende
muss man die muss man zwei sachen publishen habe ich doch am ende muss man zwei sachen
publishen geht das nicht ah low brain ich kann kein jason dokument direkt publishen ok
das ergibt sinn also am ende muss man publishen dieses komplette ding dieses komplette jason
und man muss das availability topic auf online setzen dass es funktioniert wir überschreiben
das an der stelle noch mal schnell und ich kann das ich guck das ich guck das jetzt auch
einfach mal schnell ab ich das wie ich das gemacht habe publish aha so habe ich das
gemacht kann ich auch jason documents direkt publishen ok wunderbar so und jetzt sollte
der sensor in home assistant angelegt werden jetzt können wir gleich mal ausprobieren
ob das ganze funktioniert wir legen den sensor jetzt nur an und bei jedem neuen bei jedem
neuen wert den das sensor bekommt das muss ich dann pushen hier drinnen das ist dann
aber einfacher das sieht dann im endeffekt einfach nur noch so aus das denke ich mir
nicht aus das habe ich schon mal gemacht weil dieses format ist echt nicht ohne dahinter
zu kommen wenn es spannend und satisfying ist ja das ist ja nice so also jetzt können
wir den sensor anlegen ich würde sagen sobald dann den sensor discovered muss ich mal kurz
gucken wie machen das jetzt am besten so also sobald dann den sensor sensors irgendwie
add oder sowas genau also sobald denn den sensor das erste mal erkennt publishen wir
das also sagen wir mqtt announce so was brauchen wir name da bin ich mir nur jetzt sicher was
wir machen ja lithium source ist pence champ ich weiß ja so wir machen also sensor wir
brauchen drei sensoren wir brauchen temperature unit ist ja grad Celsius wir brauchen battery
unit ist prozent und wir brauchen das kann ich nicht schreiben da muss ich nachgucken
illuminance das haben wir gestern gelernt wie man es ausspricht ich kann es immer noch
nicht aussprechen das ist ein lux und jetzt muss ich den namen generieren und die einzig
sinnvolle variante der name für den sensor zu generieren ist die meck die meck adresse
zu nehmen von dem jeweiligen flora sensor weil ansonsten hast du nichts was unique ist
wir können es aber testweise mal so machen temp 2 bad 3 elu oder so dass wir einfach
mal gucken ob er das denn anlegt so jetzt attachen wir uns an den mqtt broker und gucken
mal ob das anlegen prinzipiell funktioniert oder obs monka smoke macht also von der idee
auf fack was da ist es doch das ist zu weit unten pence champiges c++ das muss irgendwie
hier oben hin oder was ja mein wegen machst du jetzt was hat jetzt für schmerzen also
schauen ob das funktioniert wenn alles funktioniert sollte ich jetzt ich bin mir relativ sicher
dass funktioniert weil ich habe es schon gemacht mit dem also da wo ich her copy pastet habe
wenn alles funktioniert sollte ich jetzt ein gerät bekommen wo dann alles drinne steht
für die sensoren erst mal muss das gen aber erfolgreich sein dass er eine mqtt nachricht
schickt
warum ist es gecrasht
was ist das problem kann das sein eigentlich nicht warum crash das
warum crash das und und und arduino jason äh warum genau crash das ok wir machen das
mal anders ich mach das mal nicht hier in diesem bluetooth ding drinne wir machen das
immer hier im setup
da ist nämlich noch kein bluetooth am start nicht dass ich das jetzt in die quere kommt
wenn ich das der wähler an was schicken will während das bluetooth zeug hier dinger macht
da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen aber schauen wir mal also jetzt jetzt kann ihm ja kein bluetooth
in die quere kommen wenn es jetzt wieder crash dann habe ich auf jeden fall mich irgendwie
verkoppi pace und hab irgendeinen bug drin so connecting wifi und jetzt connecting please
ah guck jetzt hat er veröffentlicht der cool champ guck ein device ein device gefunden
der cool champ mit drei sensoren und ich weiß nicht wer im chat gefragt hat aber ja das
siehste so erkennst du homos ist dann richtig er erkennt es ist ein gerät mit drei sensoren
wenn man das so veröffentlicht das ist nice oder also im prinzip so so muss das so muss
das machen so jetzt habe ich natürlich ein problem warum warum hat es warum äh kack
das mit beim scannen ab ich hab ne idee woran das liegt wir machen das so äh wir werden
das wir werden das folgendermaßen machen wir machen wir machen einfach ein paar sleeps
rein andere chance haben wir gar nicht wir machen wir machen ein paar sleeps rein wobei
vielleicht kann man das gar nicht vielleicht kann ich gar kein wlan schicken hier im hier
im im bluetooth zeug ok ich sollte auf jeden fall mal zwei sachen machen noch wobei ich
greife dann ja nicht parallel drauf zu ne ich greife nicht parallel drauf zu es ist
eigentlich muss ich das überhaupt nicht locken macht es ja ich macht es ja nacheinander ich
mache den scan und dann mache ich und dann mache ich die schleife also ok wir machen
leute wir machen hier oben noch mal ein delay hin hier oben noch mal ein delay hin so einfach
mal ein bisschen ja gut was anderes fällt mir jetzt nicht ein der scan sollte ich das
vielleicht umdrehen sollte ich das vielleicht umdrehen zuerst scannen und dann das hier
machen mit dem update von dem sensor und dann warten ok gucken wir mal das ist natürlich
doof oder oder ich darf das kann das in diesem bluetooth callback gar nicht machen was ziemlich
doof ist weil ich muss es ja dynamisch für jedes gerät machen aber kein ding ich kann
das auch in der schleife machen das ist gar kein ding so geht das jetzt come on bra so
scan scan scan ah kommt mal jetzt hat das gefunden battery ah jetzt gehts jetzt funs ok warum
genau geht das jetzt und vorher ging es nicht was war was war jetzt das kaputte da dran
das habe ich nicht so ganz kapiert aber anscheinend gehts jetzt ok nice umgefuddelt ip leak
umg seid ihr schon drin chat wer ist schon da ip leak jetzt wirds gefährlicher jetzt
wirds hart jetzt wirds jetzt wirds ganz kritisch hier gleich gleich muss ich hier lockdown
machen alles abschalten ok aber das funktioniert gut so und jetzt muss ich noch die sensorwerte
übertragen das heißt jedes mal wenn ich ein ach im moment ich muss auch dafür sorgen
dass die ok wir machen das einfach nur mal testweise jetzt mit einem sensor normalerweise
müsste ich jetzt sowas machen nur mal so weil ich habe jetzt nur ein sensor in reichweite
von diesen dingern also sprich nur ein sensor hier von in reichweite wenn ich mehrere hätte
würde das natürlich nicht funktionieren ich kann nicht jeden sensor ein temp nennen die
müssen unic sein also sprich ich müsste dann sowas machen wie mqtt oder sagen wir mal
irgendwie name mqtt name und dann müsste ich dann quasi sowas machen wie sensor get
address ane hier brauchst grad habe ich doch hier oben address also sprich ich brauche
die meck ich brauche die meck davon oder wie auch immer string oder wie ist das hier to
string also ich müsste guck hier da stehts ja ich müsste die meck nehmen convert address
string representation addresses in the format ok also sprich ich müsste also ich brauche
die meck adresse und die meck adresse muss in den namen rein dass es unic ist wisst ihr
was ich mein also weil der zweite sensor funktioniert ja nicht ich kann ja nicht beide sensoren
hinzufügen mit dem gleichen namen das klappt ja nicht also ich müsste ich müsste sowas
machen wie to string und am besten noch nicht einfach nur to string sondern mqtt name replace
weil doppelpunkte mag er nicht doppelpunkte replace zu underscore oder sowas warum geht
das nicht was ist das wieder für c++ shit warum macht string replace nicht einfach das
was man erwartet nämlich ein zeichen durch ein anderes ersetzen replace characters with
value from another string what ok dann c++ string replace was was was ist das wieder
für den kack warum muss man da irgendeine länge angeben ich will den einen charakter
den anderen charakter ersetzen ist das zu kompliziert oder was ok wisst ihr was wir
machen wir verwenden einfach kein c++ string wir wandeln einfach in aduino string um weil
der aduino string da macht genau das jetzt ist es jetzt ist es ein aduino string der
aduino string macht das ein charakter durch den anderen charakter excellent wunderbar
so und jetzt können wir den kram nämlich auch folgendermaßen nennen genau jetzt kann
man das nämlich auch so nennen nicht ein stemp sondern ach du leute gleich huge mac adressen
leak massive mac adressen leak von meinem sensor by the way das sind custom funktionen von
mir die ich mit mit hier fmt lip gemacht habe weil weil der standards standards string formatting
in c++ ist mir auch zu pains champ ich so also das heißt wir nennen das ding jetzt temp underscore
ok moment chat include linux in it das klingt wie irgendwas was du lokal bräuchtest oder
nee das ist irgendwas aus dem aus dem aus dem linux kernel dann hast du nicht das dann
hast du nicht alles installiert was du brauchst no such filer directory vielleicht ist ein
make file auch einfach schlecht oder flashbang aller genau das musst du machen das musst
du machen hast du das gemacht hast du das gemacht ok dann ist ein make file wahrscheinlich
nicht passend dafür dann weiß ich nicht also das müsste dann mit müsste da eigentlich
mit funktionieren so temp mqtt so und jetzt sollten die sensoren auch richtig heißen
by the way ich lösche mal hier meinen sensor dass ich gleich sehe dass alles passt weil
so sollen die dinger gar nicht mal heißen delete delete den cool champ temp das ist
battery und das untere ist ilu nennen wir das einfach ilu gerade wenn wir schon alles
abkürzen ist es auch einfach bett bett underscore kann man es noch speichern ok das ist eine
gute idee gebe ich dir recht but so ist perfekt alle vier buchstaben lang triggert ja wäre
ich auch triggert hast du recht ok jetzt wird das ding announced und so das passt alles
name ist die mech adresse das heißt es ist auf jeden fall auch unic so und nun müssen
wir werte veröffentlichen also sprich wir sagen jetzt an der stelle mqtt publish value
name name ach so das muss ich jetzt jedes jahr jedes mal machen ok das ist nicht so
nice aber gut was willst du machen also das hier ist die temperatur temperatur ist neuer
wert ist value so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert so und dann haben wir
hier unten noch neuer value für ilu so und wenn ich das jetzt hoch lade dann sollte der
ein gerät anlegen die sensoren anlegen und neue werte pushen by the way die batterie
brauche ich noch die batterie brauche ich noch batterie update ist hier unten dankeschön
für den zapf wenn haben wir den ice freak 16 monate hyper subscription massives ab
dankeschön so dann veröffentlichen wir das hier zwar sensor mqtt name value heißt ja
hier natürlich immer wieder nicht value weil ich den kram nicht einheitlich benennet battery
level alles klar upload so wenn wir jetzt richtig gemacht haben sollte alles funktionieren
oh oh moment wir haben eine sache vergessen aber abbrechen ich sollte sicherstellen dass
das announcing von diesem sensor nur passiert wenn der sensor neu erkannt wird würde ich
sagen weil ansonsten veröffentlichen hat es jedes mal und es sagt ziemlich das soll
es nur machen wenn der sensor neu erkannt wird also gucken wir mal sensor kann ich
irgendwie checken has key oder so wie check ich ob in der ob ob was nen key in in in in
der hashtag map drinne ist die komp much size die gibt es da kein has key oder sowas ok
google standard map has key auto check if standard map contains key count
die sprache macht mich fertig was bad wird noch mit richtig gute sprache aber ernsthaft
was eine scheiße alter das kreis das cremium ist echt das können nur verrückte sein ups
also was soll ich sagen sensors count count address so also sprich dann muss ich jetzt
ein if mache wahrscheinlich if count address größer null ne gleich gleich null dann weiß
ich es ist leer ob es wo habe ich den kram hier ich habe es gelöscht ich kann knob wo
ist es da war es ich habe es gesehen da eben war es da hier das brauche ich so so jetzt
wird es nur einmalig einmalig published man könnte man könnte das eigentlich auch das
annuncen könnte man eigentlich auch hier in dieser schleife machen nämlich beim ersten
batterie abfragen dann wird es alle fünf stunden republished es gibt keine null pointer
exception weil ich keine exceptions aktiviert habe das heißt der esp crashed einfach wenn
es exception gibt wisst ihr eine sache was die wirklich in c++ 13 erfinden sollten oder
endlich mal machen sollten in c++ 13 die sollten endlich mal dafür sorgen dass dieser ganze
header scheiß wegkommt die sollen sich mal ordentliches modul ordentliches export gedünst
überlegen dann kann man nämlich auch ordentliche package manager für c++ machen und pains
gem nicht so extrem rum das muss weg das ist das ist einfach so antik das muss weg du bist
auf die sprache gekommen als erste sprache z zu lernen moment moment moment moment
c ist super c++ ist kacke was was kommt also ich habe ich habe einen compiler mit c++ 20
support und ich schreibe soweit es geht auch schon alles in line ne c++ hat eigentlich
außer ein paar sündtags sachen mit ja gott sei dank aber das hat es in c++ 20 nicht reingeschafft
ne das kommt erst mal 23 jetzt es hat es in 20 nicht einmal geschafft da habe ich mich
nämlich echt drauf gefreut da kommt nämlich dieser ganze header header crap weg das könnte
c++ vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser machen c++ und c sind in großen teilen vielleicht
kompatibel zueinander also gerade mal c zu c++ aber es gibt sachen die sind gültiges c
aber kein gültiges c++ umgedreht gibt es ganz viele sachen ja 99 prozent gültiges
c++ ist kein gültiges c zum beispiel struct initialisierung ist gültig in c und nicht
in c++ also diese punkt diese punkt das hat es echt noch in 20 geschafft das haben die
doch nicht mehr hingekriegt das haben die doch nicht da habe ich letztens irgendwas
drüber gesehen haben das echt haben das echt noch geschafft
ja sowas sowas wäre halt echt praktisch wobei wahrscheinlich kann mein compiler das wieder
nicht ach die haben das nicht implementiert ok es geht sie sehen modules was haben die
denn da drinne zeigt mal her support was ist deine meinung zu rust rust ist extrem nice
aber zu big brain ok das müsste dass sie immer noch hätte
ok das sind die basic headers ok ok das muss ich mir tatsächlich mal angucken ob das schon
ob ich das schon verwenden kann wir können doch einfach mal ausprobieren ob ich das schon
verwenden kann export module braucht man ein eigenes c-file für das muss ich jetzt mal
kurz testen das jetzt schon geht aus cacq cc module ja meinetwegen und was soll ich
in main moment was muss ich in main dafür importen import hello warum hello achso weil
es export module hello ist das muss bestimmt hello cc heißen sonst funktioniert es wahrscheinlich
nicht ha ha lull ok mein compiler stellt ganz glaube nicht
nope wäre ja auch zu schön gewesen wie aktiviere ich das denn minus f bild flex kann ich das
einfach hier reinschreiben was ist rename rename export keyboard export not implemented
ok ja das habe ich schon das habe ich schon das habe ich schon muss ich vielleicht hier
noch minus f oder so machen ok er backt unrecognized commands er macht da ein ok ich glaube mal
ich glaube mein compiler kann es schlicht und ergreifend noch nicht auch drauf geschissen
jetzt weg hello elite bm das dauert wahrscheinlich noch 20 jahre bis man das realistisch gesehen
benutzen kann hey guck mal meine sensoren sind da leute habt das gesehen meine sensoren
sind am start fast zumindest ich muss doch mal kurz abbrechen das sieht irgendwie procken
aus so bitte jetzt stehen geblieben es ernaut er announced das einmalig ok temp und die
temperatur ja das müsste eigentlich genauso funktionieren wie ich mir das vorgestellt
hab wir sollten vielleicht noch eine debug ausgabe machen hier drinnen und zwar bei
jedem schleifendurchlauf geben wir aus was der was da für aktuelle werte drin stehen
an ansonsten finden was nicht value dort but aber temp und und und illu ob das ist besser
so von piler support mal her während es gerade kompiliert schauen wir mal c++ 2 b module
modules acht ja ich habe den gcc acht also sie lang gcc muss gucken fuck
ok ja kein wunder deswegen kann es das nicht ich habe den gcc achter zwar angeblich irgendwie
zweit das ist das ist auch so hinterher gewusst äh meine güte denn so bat ist schon da ok
der sensor also wahrscheinlich weil er ihn schon erkannt hat ich muss mal ich muss übrigens
ich glaube das ist tatsächlich null das ist tatsächlich null weil ich muss mal licht
anmachen also über dem sensor die lampe lampe ist an jetzt sollte das jetzt sollte illumination
gleich ein bisschen hochgehen das ist nicht so das schnellste der sensor und dauert vielleicht
auch ein bisschen mit dem abfragen warum warum er kennt jetzt eigentlich keine temperatur
mehr gerade da hat auch die ganze zeit vorher temperatur erkannt warum er kennt er jetzt
keine temperatur mehr hier das frage ich mich auch aber er kennt
da grad gar nichts mehr ich rieche irgendwie einen back der erkennt
nichts mehr aber batterie ist angeblich wieder 100 prozent ok vorher war es 99 alles in ordnung
das kalt das ding liegt neben mir unter der lampe aber die batterie funktioniert also
die batterie abfrage funktioniert weil die batterie ist standardmäßig null die batterie
standardmäßig batterie abfrage funktioniert wisst ihr was sein kann haben wir jemals getestet
ob nach einer batterie abfrage er den rest auch noch erkennt ok ich ich disable mal kurz
das ganze mqtt zeug das muss ich jetzt mal kurz überprüfen das kann ich lassen kommt
weg an einer stelle habe ich noch hier soll das ganze mqtt zeug ist weg so und das wlan
wlan mache ich auch weg so jetzt habe ich ein problem mal gucken ob er das jetzt erkennt
wisst ihr was nämlich sein kann dass das dass ich mit dem scan das gerät in irgendein
komischen modus versetze dass es danach nicht mehr broadcasted
oder dass es komisch komische dinger broadcasted besser gesagt ja ip 00 ist klar setzt du
jemals die temperatur und felder ja mache ich ok batterie 99 prozent jetzt ist wieder
99 prozent jetzt ist 100 prozent ok das warum fragt er warum fragt also der fragt die batterie
nicht so viel ab by the way warum ist es überhaupt jetzt 100
ich setze das nur an einer stelle ich setzt batterie setzt sich nur an einer stelle und
diese sache sollte er eigentlich nur einmal alle fünf stunden abfragen ich bin verwirrt
die batterie darf sich gar nicht bewegen die batterie darf einmal in fünf stunden abgefragt
für einen moment moment habe ich ihn jetzt drin ist meine logik hier falsch fünf stunden
ja batterie 99 genau
danach darf die sich nicht mehr ändern
ich setze glaube ich den last check nie kann das sein
ich setze den last check doch dachte schon ich dachte schon das wäre es aber ich dachte
schon das wäre es das wäre relativ easy gewesen
ich muss mal die 30 milliarden debugdinger weg machen sonst sehe ich ja gar nichts mehr
du machst minus last check falsch nee eigentlich stimmt
wir machen jetzt einfach jemanden ausgabe jetzt einfach hier serial print line skip
moment moment jetzt setzt sich das hier irgendwie drin oh man oh bin ich doof lull warum steht
denn hier sowas drinnen monka weh alter wo kommt der scheiß her warum habe ich den 100
fuck aber mal ernsthaft warum fragt er denn das batterie warum fragt er denn
das warum fragt warum findet er denn die anderen die anderen sensor dinger kratten
nicht mehr wir geben noch mal typ wir geben noch mal typ und und länge mit aus bei länge
sollte ja eigentlich zwei sein und drei und oft seit sonst was skip skip skip alles gut
ergibt sinn batterie level noch mal ein ich glaube ich glaube ich weiß was ist wenn man
die batterie abfragt setzt das bestimmt das gerät in irgendeinen doofen zustand den man
wieder zurücksetzen muss die machen doch hier sowas moment so was habe ich jedoch gesehen
hier guckt mal das ist das was ich vorher ignoriert habe force force flora service data
mode force flora service data mode was macht das was was für was was was für was ist
das was was was tut es ok länge 3 länge 1 typ 63 das stimmt überhaupt was das ergibt
keinen sinn typ 63 typ 63 ist komplett verkehrt was hier haben wir uns den typ 63 gab es doch
gar nicht was ist typ 63 63 gibt es überhaupt nicht ok wir haben wir haben das gerät irgendwie
kaputt gemacht wir haben wir haben das gerät irgendwie zerstört also nicht nicht wirklich
zerstört sondern ich wette mit euch wenn ich die batterie abfrage rausmache moment
habe ich das überhaupt als hex drinne ob es auch wirklich 63 ja ich habe es als hex
so ich mache jetzt die batterie abfrage auswetten dann geht es wieder auf vorhin halb 63 halb
63 hä das sollte der nicht machen irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob wir den sensor geschrottet
haben oder so mit irgendwas aber der sendet äußerst äußerst komische dinge woran könnte
das denn liegen ausschalten wieder einschalten den flora reboot ja das machen wir jetzt ich
warte aber bis der sensor wieder läuft ich warte kurz ich warte bis der sensor wieder
läuft bis der bis type 63 flora 63 le getappt
das ist typ 63 nicht abkacken wieder was ist denn hier los mit dem 0 x 63
Okay, dazu gibt es gar nichts.
Okay, also guck mal, der Sensor schickt nur so ganz merkwürdige Dinger.
63 und ich starte den jetzt gleich mal neu, den Sensor.
Habe ich sonst vielleicht irgendwas falsch gemacht?
Data Index plus zwei, Data Index plus drei, das habe ich auch so gemacht.
Gut, also irgendwas stimmt mit dem Sensor und ich habe den Sensor irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Ich muss gerade mal aufmachen und, Alter, wenn ich das scheiß mal aufkriegen würde.
Keck wait, hallo, wow, okay, die Abdeckung ist sonst wohin geflogen gerade.
Okay, ich reboote mal, ist wieder an, FD, what, alter Sensor, was sendest du da?
Sensor gerippt, das glaube ich nicht, ich kann doch nicht durch pure Abfragen den Sensor
kaputt gemacht haben.
Ich habe bestimmt irgendwas dummes hier gemacht.
Mal alles rausschmeißen, was man hier braucht.
Was habe ich hier kaputt gemacht, ich weiß nicht genau was, das war zu Pain's Champ,
ich würde den Sensor, ja, ich verstehe, dass das Paint, aber der kaputt kann der nicht
sein, das ergibt doch keinen Sinn, sollte der kaputt sein.
Okay, was wir, wir clear Results ist das vielleicht ein Problem, aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
das habe ich glaube ich geändert vorhin, ich mache Wifi raus, brauchen wir nicht, hätte
ich mal einen Shit Commit gemacht vorhin, ne, Leute, Shit, Shit Committed, dann hätte
ich jetzt einfach mal Rollbacken können und vergleichen, Lul, ein Shit Commit, oh geht
das nicht, was ist da kaputt, meint ihr wirklich, der Sensor ist kaputt, aber von was, von was
soll denn der Sensor kaputt gehen, ich kann auch noch Batteriewerte und so abfragen, Type
8, okay, okay, ich glaube der geht wieder, Type 8 gibt's, Type 8 ist Bodenfeuchtigkeit
oder sowas, das geht, okay, ich glaube der Sensor geht wieder, welcher Sensor, der da,
äh, der Flora Sensor, okay, es geht wieder Leute, es geht wieder, was war's denn jetzt,
was genau war's denn jetzt, Include vom Wifi, ey, das ist wieder typische C++ Hatter Wahnsinn,
wenn das der Fall ist, das redefined irgendwelche Sachen davon, was soll denn Programm, äh,
Sensor kaputt machen, eventuell, weil der will nicht mehr, ey, jetzt ist wieder alles
okay, hä, what the fuck, okay, weißt was, wir machen jetzt einfach mal eine Runde Undo,
Ando, Ando, Ando, oh nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht so viel Andun, okay, perfekt, los, perfekt,
so jetzt ist alles wieder drin, ich glaube doch, dass das Batteriel Level kaputt macht,
ist jetzt auch das Wifi wieder drin, ach nee, Moment, Wifi ist noch aus, na okay, schadet
ja nix, Wifi ist noch aus, okay, denke 2, Typ 0, jetzt ist es wieder kaputt, nee, das
ist jetzt wieder kaputt, Type 63 ist wieder angesagt, puh, okay, aber das schöne ist,
ich kann jetzt einfach mal, okay, also wir wissen so, so hat es funktioniert, ne, das
ist aus mit, mit auskommentiertem Wifi und allem, so hat es funktioniert, wenn es jetzt
nicht funktioniert, dann wissen wir, dass es an der Abfrage von der Batterie liegt,
die den Sensor in einen komischen Zustand bringt, was erstmal ein paar Minuten dauert,
bis es wieder weg geht, und was jetzt, geht es jetzt, auf, mach hinne, Type 8, nee, jetzt
funktioniert es, okay, wo ist, hä, was, was macht es kaputt Leute, ich bin echt extrem
verwirrt gerade, was macht es kaputt, na die IP wird es nicht sein, Wifi einkommentieren
wird es auch nicht sein, das da vielleicht, hä, oder doch das Clear Result, du weißt
warum ist es denn plus plus, ja das ist sicherlich auch ein Teilproblem, aber das ist gerade
irgendwas Hardware-mäßiges, okay, was meinte, geht es jetzt, lag es an dem Clear Result,
nee, alles in Ordnung noch, noch ist alles gut, noch ist alles gut, funktioniert, ja
Lichtsensor, wunderbar, wunderbar, okay, was kommt als nächstes, der MQTT-Sensor, und
das da, okay, machen wir das da rein, woran könnte das liegen, das verstehe ich net, also
wenn es jetzt wieder kaputt ist, ist jetzt auch die Batterie wieder drin, Batterie, nee,
die Batterie ist nicht drinne, jetzt ist kaputt Leute, es ist kaputt, okay, wo, woran liegt
es jetzt, das macht es kaputt, was, warum, nur mal um das zu verifizieren, ich mache
das wieder raus und jetzt gehts, was ist denn daran, irgendeine Art und Weise, was hat denn
da irgendwie was mit Bluetooth zu tun davon, Debugger gibt es da nicht, da brauchst du
ein Hardware-Teil für zum Debuggen, jetzt gehts wieder, okay, Zeile 107, das da, ja
gut, das können wir nicht ausprobieren, da muss ich das hier auskommentieren zu, Bluetooth
und Wi-Fi gleichzeitig, äh gerade nicht, nein, ansonsten schon und das funktioniert
auch, so, nee es ist noch ganz, okay es ist noch ganz, also liegt es hier dran, liegt es
hier dran, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns der Sache auf jeden Fall, ich mein es kann
hier nur noch an einem dieser Zeilen hier liegen und das hier kann es nicht sein, weil
das haben wir die ganze Zeit auskommentiert gehabt, das kann ja im Prinzip nur noch da
dran oder da dran liegen und jetzt, jetzt ist es kaputt, die Zeile macht es kaputt, die
Zeile macht es kaputt, aber warum, warum, das ist doch vollkommen legitim, okay liebe
C++-Kenner, ähm, irgendjemand eine chlorische Idee, geh noch mal nach unten hier, Moment,
was hat es jetzt kaputt gemacht, das da oder das da unten, wartet mal, wartet mal, was
hab ich aus, äh, das Address ist die aktuelle Bluetooth Adresse, okay jetzt bin ich verwirrt,
wartet mal, hat es das jetzt kaputt gejagt oder das andere, ah ne, ne, ne, ne, Moment,
das stimmt nicht, das macht es gar nicht kaputt, das hier macht es kaputt, ich lass noch mal
kurz laufen, ja, ja, ne, ne, das passt jetzt, das macht es kaputt, das replays, wahrscheinlich
ist es das replays, ich weiß woran das liegt, ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt, das
ist aber mega painschempig, kann das sein, jetzt ist es kaputt, ja, kann das sein, dass
das hier keinen neuen String erstellt, sondern, dass das auf der darunter liegenden, äh,
das macht ein Android, das macht einen Arduino String draus, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht
das Problem, aber wir können ausprobieren ob das das Problem ist, achso ne, das ist
eine Arduino Funktion, könnte das sein, dass ToString keinen String erstellt, sondern als
Basis das darunter liegende, das darunter liegende, ähm, die darunter liegenden Bytes
nimmt und ich hier drinnen quasi auf den darunter liegenden Bytes rumwurste, ToString erstellt
ein neues Objekt, das weißt du ja nicht, das ist eine Implementierung von denen, return
String Sternchen This, sicher, sicher, ich wäre mir da nicht so sicher ob es das macht
ehrlich gesagt, jaja, ok an dem Replay liegt es nicht, an dem Replay liegt es nicht, wie
an dem Replay liegt das, Moment, wie kann das, wie kann das denn irgendwas kaputt machen,
also was das macht ist folgendes, äh, es ist Big Brain Template Geschiss, das macht
eigentlich, das macht eigentlich gar nichts außer, äh, die ganzen Argumente aneinander
hängen, also es macht, es macht, ist das ein Bug, ne, das macht gar nichts damit, warte
mal, wait a minute, warum ist das jetzt immer noch kaputt, warum, warum kann das überhaupt
kaputt gehen wenn das ToString macht, ach Moment, deprecated ist das, ich verwende
irgendwas deprecated, das, häh, ok, es ist immer noch kaputt, es liegt nicht an meinem,
warum, warum, wie kann es das hier denn mein Bluetooth kaputt machen, wie kann diese Zeile
mein Bluetooth kaputt, häh, das ist, ok, das ist ein Bug, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Bug,
das schreibt in irgendwo, ich wette mit euch, das schreibt irgendwo im Speicher rum wo es
nicht rumschreiben soll, so, wir machen jetzt mal testweise was anderes, ich mach das mal
ganz weg und mach da einfach sowas hier rein, das sollte jetzt ja nix mal machen, schönes
Beispiel für wie man sich mit C++ übrigens in Fuß schießen kann hier wieder, und, Hallo,
hab null, ok, jetzt funktioniert's wieder, funktioniert wieder, ok, das liegt definitiv
hier dran, attr toString, MQTTname verwende ich sonst nirgendswo mehr, gut, hier im Sensor,
das ist erstmal egal, das liegt nur hier dran, das wird er wahrscheinlich wegoptimieren
und deswegen wird es jetzt doch funktionieren, ja, das probier ich gleich aus, aber ich verstehe
nicht was, das ist irgendein Bug, das ist irgendein Bug, ist es doch, es ist kaputt,
der pure Aufruf von attr.toString macht mein Bluetooth kaputt, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ja hier, da ist er, da passiert nicht so viel, die Frage ist nur, was this in dem
Fall überhaupt ist, wie, wie, wie kann der das zu nem String konvertieren überhaupt,
wie geht denn das, die müssen, die müssen, das Ding muss in irgendeiner Art und Weise
konvertierbar sein, daraus, wie auch immer die das gemacht haben, ah, hier, Operator,
ah, fuck it, die Operator, Cast Overloading oder sowas ist das jetzt auch noch, hier,
hier, hier, hier, hier, das macht es kaputt Leute, ich sag es euch, das macht es kaputt,
das verkackts irgendwie, hier machen die irgendwas kaputt, die machen da irgendwas kaputt hier,
irgendwas, irgendwas ist hier repp, irgendwas ist hier verbugged dran, da wird kein Speicher
geändert, doch, die schreiben in Buffer und wenn das hier irgendwie zu lang ist oder so,
das macht es irgendwie kaputt, wir probieren mal folgendes aus, anstatt zu String, gehen
wir mal, was weiß ich, Get Native, Get Native, Get Native ist nen, Array, ok, da passiert
jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts, Address ist die Bluetooth, die Bluetooth Mac Adresse quasi
von dem Gerät, so, da passiert jetzt nichts, wenn da jetzt auch was passiert, dann blick
ich schnell mal durch, und das sieht schon mal besser aus, na, es funktioniert, ok,
Get to String macht es einfach kaputt, so, dann probieren wir mal aus, was passiert,
wenn man, Standard String, Stronk, Stronk, Big, Big, Standard Stronk, Stronks müssten
auch geben, so, und das soll jetzt funktionieren oder was, so, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
mal gucken, ob es das jetzt auch kaputt macht, was ein Scheiß, Alter, mit was man sich hier
wieder befassen muss, ich dachte, da sind wir 15 Jahre drüber, drüber raus, jetzt,
das ist kaputt, ok, Leute, das liegt, das liegt daran, das liegt hieran, das liegt an
diesem, an diesem String Constructor Ding oder so, die machen da irgendwelches, da
ist irgendein Bug drinne, das Overfloat, Underfloat, über, über, seitwärts, Diagonalfloat, irgendwas,
keine Ahnung, ja, so, da ist irgendwas kaputt drinne, das heißt, wir müssen das jetzt selbst
machen, Get, Native, oder was haben die noch für Methoden, Get Type, oh, Big Brain, was
ist das, wow, ach so, das ist das Overloaded Operator, aber man kann das auch, man kann
das auch zu einem, man kann das auch zu einem Int64 machen, also kann ich jetzt so was hier
machen, Uint64, kann ich das cast on, ok, das funktioniert, Auskernfuchs, könnte man
bestimmt machen, aber ich würde jetzt mal von denen erwarten, dass die, dass das funktioniert,
ja, ich könnte das bestimmt in irgendeiner Art und Weise kopieren, ja, aber so geht es
ja auch, wenn es jetzt nicht kaputt geht, dann benutze ich halt das Int und anscheinend
geht es jetzt komplett kaputt, dass es gar nicht mehr weiter scannt, ok, ich resette
nochmal, ach ne, doch, es geht weiter, ich habe nichts gesagt, ok, das geht, das geht,
alles klar, das geht, wunderbar, so, was, was, was, was, was habe ich denn da als drinstehen,
was habe ich denn da als drinstehen, MQTT, nee, Uint64, da habe ich die MAC Adresse
als, als, 6 bytes konvertiert zu einem Uint6, ja, das geht auch, das ist auch Unic, kann
man das nicht, das ist doch ein Objekt, ok, das, das passt, damit kann ich leben, da nehme
ich halt nicht die MAC Adresse, die man gut lesen kann, sondern eben die MAC Adresse als
bytes, ist auch in Ordnung, kann ich auch mit leben, wunderbar, passt, exquisite, excellent,
hoch 10, ja, jetzt funktioniert es, excellentst ist das, excellent, excellent reicht immer,
es ist excellentst, gibt es das Wort überhaupt, kann man excellent überhaupt noch steigern,
es ist in Wirklichkeit, wenn ihr mal in der Schule gefragt werdet, es ist nicht gut, besser,
am besten, es ist gut, besser, excellent, excellentst, so, also, weiter, Slayda Teddy
10 Monate, danke für den Sub, ok, das heißt, wir wissen jetzt wo was liegt, wir können
den ganzen Scheiß wieder rückgängig machen, ich kann alles wieder einkommentieren, was
ich auskommentiert habe, und mich freuen, dass es funktioniert, sehr gut, excellent,
warte, was mache ich da, so weit muss ich nicht zurück, so, ist das WiFi, ist das WiFi,
noch WiFi drinnen, WiFi begin, excellent, ok, alles klar, das heißt, wir machen kein
Tool String, wir machen ein, wir konvertieren das Ding zu einem Uint, Uint64 und dann zu
einem String, beste, wobei, nee, war aber nicht, hier, ups, wir nehmen einfach das
Int und das hier machen wir einfach auch zu einem Uint64, Uint64, ok, wunderbar, jetzt
sollte wieder alles funktionieren, gehen wir mal in Home Assistant und löschen den Sensor,
da ist er, der exzellente Sensor, zack, next, go back, hallo, ok, zip, upload, ja, kann
man, adjektiv exzellent, ok, oh, oh, oh, oh, das ist gut, das muss ich bemerken, exzellent,
exzellenter, am exzellentesten, das ist nicht exzellent, sondern es ist am exzellentesten,
ok, das muss ich gucken, wie das ausgefroren wird hier, ah, yes, hier lernt man wieder
was, hier lernt man wieder was, aha, ah, yes, jetzt, warum ist feminine exzellent eher,
wie kann das sein, exzellenter, exzellenter, ja, halt nicht klar, Leute, nein, nein, das
ist wieder kaputt, oder, ne, ne, ne, ne, er hat die Temperatur auf jeden Fall ausgelesen
jetzt schon mal, aber jetzt ist die Temperatur wieder weg, ah, Moment, ich hatte hier noch
den Bug drinnen mit den 100, so, ich mach mal kurz hier dieses ganze D-Bug Zeug raus,
ich glaub, das geht jetzt, ich glaub, ich hab noch einen anderen Bug, Moment, abbrechen,
das kommt auch wieder rein, also, wenn das jetzt nicht funktioniert, dann ragequit ich
gleich, es scheint mir ein exzellenter, exquisiter Stream ist das heute, oh, kann das das hier
auch diese Seite, exquisite, exquisite, exquisites, was, exquisites, was ist das für ein Wort,
was ist ein exquisites, exquisites, die Mehrzahl, davon gibt's doch keine Mehrzahl, oder, die
Exquisite, der, hä, das ergibt keinen Sinn, ok, das klingt mir falsch, ok, alles gut,
es funktioniert, es funktioniert, wunderbar, was sagt, was sagt der Home Assistant, der
Cool Champ ist am Start, Batterie, jawoll, bam, nur Batterie geht grad nicht, aber guck
mal, er überträgt, alles gut, wunderbar, Poggers, Poggers, was ich noch nicht so ganz
verstehe ist, ah, ich setz den Sensorwert hier unten, Sensor, Temp, gleich Value, wisst
ihr mal, alles, alles muss man selbst machen, nie hilft mir einer, Chat, und das, ah, Moment,
das ist Temp und das ist, so, und jetzt können wir das hier ausgeben und dann passt das alles,
das ist für die Batterie, ok, und jetzt sollte eigentlich alles funktionieren, ja, die Update
in der Realtime, ist das nicht Poggers, so, auf, zeig's uns, mach, mach, mach, mach, mach,
zeig's uns, mach, Type 0, Type 0 ist schlecht, 99 Batterie, Länge, Temp, genau, Beleuchtung
haben wir, 135, perfekt, jetzt warten wir nur bis Temperatur abgefragt wird, Temperatur,
das dauert ein bisschen, bis sich das zufälligerweise scannt, während es gerade verschickt, das
kann ein bisschen dauern, ja, das kann, das kann schon mal, im Zweifelsfall, zwei, drei
Minuten dauern, aber, das muss ich ja gerade überschneiden mit, dass er scannt und das,
ah, Batterie, Temp, 23, Leute, funktioniert, funktioniert, guckt da, Bäm, Batterie Level,
99, Beleuchtung, mal kurzzeitig, wir können es ja testen, ob die Beleuchtung funktioniert,
ich mach jetzt die, ok, ok, Massive, Massive Crafts, Leute, ja, Big Brain Crafts, ich mach
jetzt die Beleuchtung von der Elgato auf, das sollte jetzt gleich auf Null gehen, also
gleich, demnächst sollte das auf Null gehen, so, Elgato Beleuchtung ist aus, jetzt warten
wir mal, wie lang es dauert, mal gucken, ob das auch Realtime updatet, updatet, sollte
es jetzt runter auf Null gehen, dann machen wir die Elgato Lampe an, oh, es ist sogar
hochgegangen, Kek Wait, Wait, Kek Wait, ok, das war eine Verzögerung, irgendwie,
jetzt ist es Null, ok, ob ich, aber die Verzögerung ist für den Kühlschrank-Sensor nur durchaus
in Ordnung, ja, ok, und jetzt mach ich die Elgato Lampe mal auf volle, volle, volle
Pulle, der Bastel-Champ ist volle Pulle, auf, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
hochkant
Unter unter den direkt unter unter den elgato stellts
Dann fällt es direkt rein
Oh
Okay
Morgengemüse erstens weil ich gucken wollte wie man plutos sachen abfragt und zweitens weil
Das nicht passiv lauscht sondern aktiv das gerät abfragt und das kostet so viel batterie
Und die projekte die passiv abfragen fragen nicht die batterie ab
Ich habe es jetzt so gemacht ich lausche passiv was das gerät für sensorwerte schickt
Und alle fünf stunden frage ich einmal die batterie ab das so das beste aus beiden welten finde ich okay funktioniert leute
Nice
Batterie 99 prozent 1008 als schlugs 23,1 grad perfekt
Ja das ist cool
So ein bisschen pains champiger code aber es funktioniert
Gamepad dankeschön für den primes ab
Und jetzt ab in den cool champ leute soll ich mal soll ich mal in kühlschrank legen und wir wollen mal zugucken
Soll ich mal ich kann rüber gehen in kühlschrank in der hoffnung ich habe den controller so liegen dass es noch vom kühlschrank funktioniert
Weil die sache ist die jetzt ist es so der kühlschrank ist wirklich auf der anderen seite vom stockwerk
Manchmal funktioniert vielleicht manchmal nicht
Ich werde natürlich den controller dann in flur machen weil ich will ja auch noch das müssen wir auch noch irgendwann an der nächsten striefe meine waage
Meine waage verschickt ja auch über bluetooth die werte die sollen ja auch noch rein
Pippo fett champ ich bringe sie kühlschrank
Ups ich habe mich schon gemutet ich kann ich starte mal neu ihr habt es gar nicht gehört wie ich unter tisch gekrabbelt bin
Ich starte mal neu ich habe es noch nicht im kühlschrank
Ich will jetzt erstmal gucken dass er alles erkennt
Ok batterie 99 wollte nämlich gucken dass das gerät auch auf jeden fall alles
Temperatur hat er erkannt alles klar ok ich werde jetzt den kühlschrank bringen
Zack
ist das gerade noch hochgegangen wo ich schon wieder da war 24,8 null
ja wahrscheinlich weil ich es in der hand hatte ok illumination 0 ist es ja im kühlschrank
und es ist dunkel datenlöschen nö nö wir gucken da jetzt zu wie es kälter wird
aktuell haben wir noch 3 und noch 24,8 wie viel platz ist auf dem ganzen flash noch für lips
gucken wir mal 25 prozent also nenne mal so viel aber das reicht also für einen web interface mit
ota sollte das noch reichen so wir müssen jetzt abwarten ob das ding sich meldet aus
im kühlschrank das problem ist nämlich so wirklich weiß ich nicht ob es funktioniert
22,5 geht runter es droppt plus usb ip ne ne das ding geht ja komplett über den wlan ich
kann es auch so alles abfragen ich werde das werde das in flur hängen wenn es so weit ist
aber es funktioniert 22,5 leute beobachtet das mal ich gehe mal kurz pinkeln
und
funktioniert der kühlschrank champ hat schon nichts getan sonst oder oder hat sich was getan
22,5 naja also es könnte jetzt ein problem sein also es könnte ein problem sein dass es jetzt
nicht das signal kommt durch es hat eben schon 22,5 gemeldet da war es ja schon im kühlschrank
das problem ist dass nicht mehr jedes signal durchkommt es kommt wir haben es jetzt letzte
mal getestet es kommt normalerweise sind sie in fünf sechs signale die kommen alle durch wenn
das ding im kühlschrank liegt kommt nur noch ein signal oder zwei signale durch von irgendwie
56 und er muss genau zur gleichen zeit zufällig scannen während das ding das schickt also es
ist auf jeden fall sinnvoller das ding in flur zu hängen anstatt hier am rechner hängen zu
lassen ich mein ich kann den ich kann den scan intervall ne dauer scan kann ich nicht weil ich
wlan an hab wenn ich dauer scanne kackt das wlan ab oh guck mal 15,7 ist runtergegangen
habt ihr gesehen 15,7 also es funktioniert alles hat halt ein bisschen verzögert aber
damit kann ich leben zumal wenn das im flur hängt dann ist es auch besser vom empfang
her was für ein wappen der fest das ist haumassistent wie kalt wird es noch ja 10 grad oder so wo das
liegt beides in den kühlschrank ne da komme ich im wlan nicht richtig raus dann das ding
kommt in flur das ding kommt in flur oder vielleicht neben den kühlschrank aber nicht
in den kühlschrank und das soll dann auch die waage auf am bad empfangen übrigens ich
habe mir das interessiert ich habe als waage me scale ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher welche
me scale ich muss mal kurz bei amazon gucken die haben wir auch mal im stream schon ausprobiert
by the way ich muss mal kurz gucken welche version weil das entscheidend ist was ich machen muss
dafür scale me body composition scale ok scale 2 habe ich ne scale 2 scale 2 blue truth esp 32
guck da bäm da kann man sich abgucken wie das funktioniert mit der waage ab
wo man sind immer so viel bei den was haben wir jetzt 15,1 hatte mir eben schon 15,1 sensor
und so und es ist runtergegangen ist runtergegangen von 15,7 auf 15,1 nein ich will das nicht ich will
mein gewicht nicht in die china china cloud hochladen leute password leak so also wie
machen wir machen der typ das hier wie kann man die waage auslesen soll das ganze mqt tt
im mqtt zeug ich kann nicht den code benutzen weil ich will es auf dem gleichen gerät laufen
lassen da will ich ja ich will ja meins haben und die waage drin so was machen die dann hier
zeig mal hier was zum geier irgendwelche string to to to int oder sowas halbe halbe die esp 32
sind eigentlich kein arduino aber die haben 13,5 die haben arduino die haben so ein arduino
compatible compatibility layer obendrauf das heißt man kann auch arduino, guck mal es geht
wirklich weiter runter man kann arduino zeug verwenden oftmals ist es allerdings sinniger
die schon eingebauten sachen zu verwenden zum beispiel für mehrere threats und tasks und sowas
so also wie machen wir machten der typ das jetzt oth ist mir auch otha ist mir auch egal callback
das ist auch nix hat auch nix mit der waage zu tun reconnect
ja das haben wir gesehen das geht zusammen
hier ok also wie zum geier lesen die sachen aus der waage aus
gern oft bla bla bla habt ihr jetzt irgendwas ach hier found devices
ask and results ok ok
ok das gucke ich mir heute definitiv nicht an das gucke ich mir in einem der nächsten
sachen an also have service data und dann wieder irgendwie magic magic sachen auslesen wo was wo
was drinne steht ok bei the way mir fällt gerade ok 12,3 schon es geht runter mir ist gerade
aufgefallen dass es für die waage gar nicht so gut funktioniert weil ich bin wieder dran ich
war ich war zwei stunden weg zwischendurch habe reifen gewechselt also direkt die idf nutzen
nee ich mache es trotzdem am liebsten mit platform i o und dem arduino aufsatz einfach weil es
ein paar libraries gibt die nice sind und du kannst ja wenn du wenn du wenn du arduino verwendest du
kannst ja auch die sachen die unten drunter sind verwenden einzige was du nicht machen kannst den
die projekt settings im idf ändern aber die standard arduino settings sind ganz ok manchmal
ist es doof weil du weil du bestimmte sachen nicht enablen kannst aber in der zu 99 prozent
ist ok wir haben auch schon mal idf projekt hier gemacht irgendwann im stream aber meistens
mache ich wirklich die arduino geschichte mir ist aufgefallen mit der waage funktioniert es gar
nicht so gut weil die waage schickt einmal nachdem es fertig ist schickt das die die werte so und das
problem ist jetzt dass so selten wie ich gerne kriege ich das garantiert nicht mit dass die
waage am start ist dass die bagging gibt es nicht die bagging kannst du printline machen oder du
brauchst ein hardware die bagger aber dafür ist das wenn du ein hardware die bagge hast es ist
hier ein plattform ganz gut integriert deswegen kann ich dir nur empfehlen den plattform
ein ok damit ist es relativ easy wer hat besseren sleep arduino nano oder die 1 mini die sind beide
nicht sonderlich gut ok den nano bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher
was es braucht 0,3 milliampere ist definitiv nicht perfekt für batterien das sind 300 microampere
das ist total viel das ist das ist ganz relativ schnell eher ok also 10 microampere ist in
ordnung mit 10 microampere kann man leben der demo mini an dem musst du ordentlich rumlöten
dass du den irgendwie auch nur halbwegs strom sparen bekommst jeezy pro 36 v2 dankeschön für
den zapp excellent subscription welcher chip ist der beste für deep sleep also wenn du
wirklich deep sleep projekte machen willst ja das trickboard wobei ich ganz ehrlich da
kein großartiger fan von bin das ist ziemlich teuer du musst es importieren es ist nur
ein esp 2866 wobei ich glaube die gibt es mittlerweile auch von esp 23 variante aber
das schaltet alles ab also du kannst auch keinen speicher mehr benutzen ja das ist halt
wirklich für ultra low power und auch nur wenn du nach time aufwachen willst das ding
hier ist gut für deep sleep das ding hier ist gut für deep sleep das ist extra dafür
gemacht und du hast direkt einen batterie connector wo du irgendwelche akkus dran machen
kannst wenn du da 1200 oder 2000 milliampere stunden akku dran machst und klein sodass
das quasi hier drunter passt dann kannst du das ding durchaus 23 jahre sleepen lassen
wenn du nur selten aufwachst natürlich ja und je nachdem wie sich der akku entlädt
aber das frisst so gut wie nichts das sind das sind im deep sleep 10 10 10 microampere
und mal kurzzeitig ein bisschen mehr wenn es aufwacht aber wenn du nur drei viermal
am tag aufwachst um was zu übertragen das hält wirklich verdammt lang gibt es auch
so ein battery life hier genau aber da gab es einen besseren da gab es einen besseren
der da der da der hier oh ne der war ganz gut der ist weg rib ne so do it yourself alexa
gibt es nicht wirklich so viel gutes es gibt das hier das aber was mich daran nervt ist
dass die dass man das handy nicht verwenden kann
ist das falsche projekt es gibt eine flatte ab wirklich echt die muss ich mal ausprobieren
aber bestimmt nicht für ios ach es moved ab wo gibt es eine ab wir würden ja sogar
eine pva oder so reichen ab wo gibt es eine ab flatter hast du mal link also das stört
mich halt dass mein handy nicht dafür verwenden kann so wie warm 10,7 grad im kühlschrank
leute des sieh gut aus was ist das gibt es für ios ok das schon mal ganz praktisch
ok aber ohne scheiß dem würde ich das sogar bezahlen die gebühren für den store
gut ich brauche schon eine app im store sonst ist er doof ok das ist schon mal ganz gut
aber das kann auch text to speech oder also ich muss da nicht tippen da kann schon text
to speech warum machen die nicht eigentlich einfach eine pva warum machen die nicht eine
pva spricht kann man kann man in einer pva nicht text to speech machen warum ist das
hier eigentlich nicht verlinkt pva ok auf die idee ist noch keiner gekommen doch ja
so lange es da keine smartphone apps für gibt ist das so ein bisschen pains champig
aber das könnte man auch mit einer pva machen das wäre doch viel sinnvoller dann muss es
auch nicht ins store da muss es auch nicht ins store bringen naja gut wie gesagt also
ohne ohne smartphone apps finde ich halt ein bisschen doof ok vielleicht hat es einen
grund warum das nicht geht mit pva so wir sind bei 10,4 grad leute das funktioniert
alles nee ich will da keine eigene app verbauen pains champ aber vielleicht funktioniert das
ja es spricht sagen wir man kann doch unter ios in der pva auf das mikrofon zugreifen
oder
ios macht man wieder einen strich durch die rechung dass die kram nicht richtig funktioniert
was ist der unterschied zwischen pva und elektron naja pva ist im prinzip nur die webseite
die dann quasi als verknüpfung auf dem homescreen ist eine elektron app müsst ihr über den
store verteilen obwohl es auch nur ein browser ist ja das ist mal wieder pains champ dass
das und der apple wohl nicht richtig funktioniert aber das vielleicht geht das doch und das
ist einfach nur alt ist der gopher flow einträge super du wirst schon mal ausprobieren aber
ich will keine eigene app machen das ist mir zu pains champ also was heißt app ich müsste
ja eine webseite einfach nur machen wenn es easy ist komm mal 10,4 nice wenn es easy ist
könnte man sich das überlegen was es ist composed of independent software ok man kann
keine app machen man kann keine app machen weil mqtt ist nicht websockets und nicht sonst
ist ein eigenes protokoll das geht über webseiten nicht da haben wir schon keine pva vielleicht
haben die aber auch die möglichkeit ist über den webservice zu machen a websocket api ok
dann ist wiederum ok dann geht das ja das wüsste ich mal ausprobieren ein bisschen
rumbasteln aber wichtig für mich ist dass es mobile apps gibt ich will mein handy in
der hand haben und zweifeln von voice kommando machen können so aber ich würde sagen 10
grad im kühlschrank ich würde sagen dass ich hier ist wirklich erfolgreich ihr seht
der sensor tut sensorik champ man könnte jetzt noch man könnte jetzt noch massive craft
champ machen sensor ist aber wie heißt mein sensor sack der ist mein sensor cool champ
warum ist er da nicht drin weil es nicht cool champ heißt sondern sollte der sensor nicht
cool champ heißen ane mecha adresse hinten dran also temp den sensor brauchen wir huge
huge crafts kwh wait a minute keck weight was ist mit dem graph los
der craft gibt überhaupt keinen sinn
komm mal so sieht der craft aus warum geht der craft da hoch
findet ihr dass das hier und das hier irgendwie ähnlich aussehen
ok aber warum
das ergibt keinen sinn ah ok das sieht besser aus das sieht besser aus das sieht besser
aus alles klar ja der cool champ ja ok was auch immer der problem war ich brauche noch
ein bisschen mehr daten ok alles klar das funktioniert gut excellent craft jetzt habe
ich meine temperatur vom kühlschrank das ist nicht nice ja wie lange hält die batterie
circa das weiß ich noch nicht aber sobald ich das in betrieb nehme werde ich das in
meinen batterie champ einbauen der batterie champ nicht nicht der heizungs champ sondern
in den managed dashboard batterie wo ich die ganzen sensor batterie oder zumindest die
meisten und die wichtigsten sensor batterien drinne habe dann sehe ich wann es der sache
zur neige geht und ich sehe dass der tür sensor unten an der eingangstür ein bisschen leer
ist darf ich fragen wieso du ein sensor in meinem kühlschrank hast also der erste sache
ist natürlich weil ich sensoren übrig habe und weil es geht das ist schon mal das wichtigste
an der sache und das nächste ist weil ich mitbekommen will wenn mein kühlschrank rum
spackt da ist nämlich ein bisschen weiß ich nicht kaputt ja doch oder zumindest nicht
darauf kaputt der muss man manchmal rebooten weil er komische geräusche macht ich habe
ein bisschen bedenken dass der mal den geist aufgibt nicht kriegt das erste tach später
und ein halben tach später mit und hier siehst du das natürlich wunderbar jetzt du hast
jetzt hier direkt drinnen temperatur vom kühlschrank temperatur vom kühlschrank doch hier mit
verlauf hier war es draußen habe hier ein bisschen kühlschrank gelegt und du siehst
den batteriestand vom sensor und ob ich die tür aufgelassen habe weil normalerweise ist
es im kühlschrank dunkel das heißt wir haben hier null helligkeit und wenn ich den kühlschrank
aufmache oder den oder das licht drinnen angeht dann kriege ich hier was und da kann
ich sagen ey wenn das licht länger an ist als zwei minuten dann mach was für was verwendest
du wie es kaut im home assistant kann man editieren kann man konfig editieren ich habe
aber das ist nur meine testinstanz ne setzt du auch notifications habe ich grad nicht
ne bin ich am überlegen aber ich gucke da so oft rein ich krieg das schon mit so 10,1
ist viel kälter wird es nicht mehr der kühlschrank ist glaub eingestellt auf unten 5 oben 10
oder es liegt in der mitte oder umgedreht passt eigentlich gut äh welches board oh ich glaub
meine katze will will rein als board habe ich grad als basis für diese geschichte habe
ich
sind. Aber der ist ernsthaft nicht schlecht. Der ist relativ klein, nicht mini, also nicht
ultra klein, auch wenn er mini heißt, aber ist okay und ist preisleistungsmäßig echt
in Ordnung. Nur für Deep Sleep und Batterie-Projekte ist das nix. Weibliche Chico, ja, es ist ein
bisschen merkwürdig, ich hab mir das nicht ausgesucht. Ähm, meine Katze. Also die da.
Wo ist der? Hier. Die da. Das Bild, äh. Oho, stinkig, das Hemd, so geil. Heißt Chico,
aber ist ne Katze. Was saugt denn den Strom auf dem Board? Hä, was meinste? Der CPU,
WLAN, Bluetooth. Aber insgesamt braucht es nicht viel, also zu Spitzenlastzeiten, keine
Ahnung, 150, 200mAh vielleicht. Also du musst dich schon ganz schön anstrengen, wenn du
mal so ein Messgerät anschließt, du musst dich schon ganz schön anstrengen, dass du
auf nen Watt kommst mit nem ESP32. Also da musst du schon, da musst du schon einiges
machen. Da musst du wahrscheinlich beide CPU Kerne voll auslasten plus WLAN und Bluetooth
machen, dass du das schaffst. Äh, droh USB, einfach USB. Was übrigens auch der Grund
ist, warum diese Boards für Deep Sleep nicht so gut sind, weil die meisten, auch wenn
sie von der Batterie gepowert werden, den USB Spannungswandler und den 5V Spannungswandler
noch versorgen und das macht halt keinen, verbraucht halt unnütz Strom, ja. Der D1
Mini, also bei dem ESP32 D1 Mini weiß ich nicht, aber bei dem alten war es so wie gesagt
die Spannungswandler für Sachen, die du eigentlich gar nicht brauchst, war noch standardmäßig
versorgt, USB war standardmäßig mit versorgt, es waren 1-2 LEDs an. Also du kannst an dem
Board rumlöten und du kriegst es bestimmt auch zu nem relativ guten Deep Sleep, aber
du hast keinen Batterie-Connector und es ist nicht für Deep Sleep gedacht. Das heißt
du kannst dir für 6,50 einfach nen Board kaufen, was gut gedacht ist für Deep Sleep und einen
Batterie-Connector hat. Ja das Problem ist, wenn du den Kram durchschneidest, du willst
das Board ja später per USB noch anschließen können, um es zu flashen. Also das ganze rumlöten
und so. Ich würd einfach nen Board nehmen, was für Deep Sleep gedacht ist. Ja, wie gesagt
das ist ne Katze. Obwohl sie Chico heißt. Aber das hab ich mir nicht ausgedacht, das
haben sich die ehemaligen Besitzer ausgedacht. Die ist ja auch schon 12 oder so jetzt. Die
haben sich halt gedacht, Chico ist ein guter Mädchennamen. Ok 10,1, exellent. Leute wisst
ihr was, ich lass das Ding heute mal über Nacht im Kühlschrank und morgen guck ich
mal was das sagt. Man kann dort nen Jumper machen oder Lötstelle. Das kann man alles
machen. Aber warum kauft man sich nicht einfach für 6,50 ein Board, was für Deep Sleep und
Batterie-Projekte gedacht ist. Problem Solved. Ok ich mach das mal ab. Leute ich geh jetzt
ins Bett. Ich bin müde. Heute ganz schön lang gestreamt. Ist da Frazier oder irgendjemand
am Start, den man hosten kann? Nope. Kein Frazier am Start. Wie der Frazier war heute
nicht da, was hier lohnt am Feiertag? Zempervideos haben wir das letzte Mal schon gehostet. Sind
2,50 Unterschiede. Wenn das für dich relevant ist, musst du halt selbst dran rumlöten und
dich mit rum ärgern. Also Leute wir sehen uns. Machts gut bis denn. CU ich hoffe euch
hat es gefallen. Waren ja viele mit am Start bis jetzt zum Schluss und heute mal echt ein
bisschen was funktioniert hat und alles gut ist. Also machts gut. Bis denn. CU.